bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce mercredi 6 janvier
le coc vide toujours et encore
conférence de presse attendue demain 18
heures avec un nouveau calendrier est
probablement un couvre-feu avancé pour
d'autres départements
les vaccins à eux étaient au coeur d'un
nouveau conseil de défense ce matin 300
centres de vaccination seront ouverts
dès la semaine prochaine
la 500 la semaine suivante un deuxième
vaccin le modern art officiellement
autorisée en europe
joe biden promet unités et actions après
la victoire probable des démocrates en
géorgie où vient d'avoir lieu le
deuxième tour des élections sénatoriales
de son côté le congrès et vient
d'entamer lui la certification de sa
victoire à la présidentielle vice
président mike pence annonce qu'il ne
s'opposera pas à cette certification de
la victoire de joe biden au grand dam de
donald trump qui lui affirme ce soir qui
ne concédera jamais la défaite
autrement je deviens assange reste en
prison deux jours après avoir refusé de
l'extrader vers les états unis
la justice britannique examinée la
demande de remise en liberté sous
caution du fondateur de wikileaks ces
soutiens reste malgré tout mobilisée et
réclame sa réhabilitation ainsi que des
indemnités pour détention arbitraire
[Musique]
conseil de défense puis premier conseil
des ministres de l'année ce matin au
programme les nouvelles mesures prises
pour enrayer l'épidémie de kobe 19 dans
l'hexagone mais aussi la stratégie
vaccinale critiqué à cause de la lenteur
du plan de vaccination le gouvernement
tente tant bien que mal de rassurer
quand un mot clair les vaccins au coeur
des discussions lors du conseil de
défense et du conseil des ministres de
ce mercredi reproché d'avoir un plan de
vaccination trop lent comparé à ses
voisins européens
le gouvernement essaie de calmer ses
détracteurs et annonce une augmentation
du nombre de centres de vaccination
élargir les publics ciblés nous avons
d'ailleurs déjà commencé à le faire tous
les soignants de plus de 50 ans peuvent
ainsi d'ores et déjà se faire vacciner
nous allons multiplier le nombre de
centres de proximité pour les soignants
et bientôt pour les personnes âgées de
plus de 75 ans en population générale
ainsi depuis ce matin le nombre
d'hôpitaux pouvant vacciner a été
multiplié par trois et nous allons
ouvrir nous ouvrons centre destiné à la
ville ce n'est qu'un début nous en
ouvrirons 300 la semaine prochaine et
500 celle d'après par la voix de son
porte parole le gouvernement annonce
l'arrivée de cinq cent mille doses du
vaccin faiza biotech chaque semaine
alors que la france en possède un
million de doses au 6 janvier
autres thèmes évoqués lors de la rentrée
ministériel les nouvelles mesures
sanitaires pour enrayer l'épidémie
le premier ministre jean castex tiendra
une conférence de presse jeudi à 18h sur
ce sujet en attendant les futures
annonces le monde de la culture mais
également les restaurateurs ne se font
guère d'illusions sur l'eau réouverture
prévue le 20 janvier et bien aujourd'hui
ce qui est clair c'est qu'on ne va pas
réouvrir le 20 janvier ça c'est un
événement parce qu'on se doutait qu'elle
par des vers le 20 janvier on n'a pas de
date
aujourd'hui ouverture nous ce qu'on
attend c'est de la visibilité ce qui a
rien de pire que de ne pas savoir
est ce qu'on va faire ce soit dans des
métiers où dans d'autres voitures
personnelles si vous souhaitez ouvrir de
façon j'oserais dire définitive quand on
va nous une date si c'est mars et mars
mais c'est pas pour fermer deux semaines
après dans le même temps certaines
stations de ski se prépare à remettre en
marche les remontées mécaniques ce jeudi
comme initialement annoncé en décembre
par jean castex le porte parole du
gouvernement gabriela talent a précisé
ce mercredi que la date du 7 janvier
doit être considérée comme je cite un
point de rendez-vous et non pas comme
une date de réouverture
les mesures de restriction la stratégie
de vaccination alors à quoi doit-on
s'attendre demain place à notre
décryptage avec adam invités pour en
parler et nous sommes avec stéphane
manigold porte parole du goût du
mouvement restons ouverts également
frédéric leturque merck sont tristes
d'arras également avec nous à arnaud
benedetti rédacteur en chef de la revue
politique et parlementaire dont soir
messieurs merci à tous les trois d'être
en direct avec nous sur rt france alors
on l'aura compris évidemment le
gouvernement qui tente de reprendre la
main un conseil de défense conseil des
ministres ce matin au menu la campagne
de vaccination très critiqué à sa sortie
le porte parole du gouvernement gabriela
talent a fait un point sur
l'accélération de cette campagne écouter
les vaccins continuent à arriver sur
notre sol nous en aurons ce soir un
total d'un million de doses et nous
recevrons 500 mille doses
supplémentaires par semaine
pour ce qui est du vaccin fader by one
tech j'ajoute que le hall agence
européenne du médicament a rendu sa
décision sur l'autorisation du vaccin
moderna et vous ne savez la haute
autorité de santé rendra son avis très
rapidement ce qui nous permettra
également d'être approvisionné pour ce
vaccin à raison de 200 mille doses sur
le premier mois puis de 500 mille doses
par mois alors un propos plutôt
optimistes de la part du porte-parole de
gouvernement c'est de nature à rassurer
frédéric leturque
je pense que de toute façon il faut
aujourd'hui qu'on se sent tous mobilisés
est tous concerné par cette séquence de
vaccination elle n'est pas simple à
mettre en place parce que pour vacciner
il faut avoir les doses de vaccin
suffisante et c'était peut-être un peu
le sujet qui était plus ou moins pas
avoué par le gouvernement s'était cette
difficulté peut-être d'être fournies en
nombre suffisant de vaccins puisque
kaiser on le sait en fait n'avait
peut-être pas capacité totalement à
satisfaire l'ensemble du spectre que
l'on voulait couvrir aujourd'hui les
choses sont claires le fait que modern a
en fait soit en quelque sorte un peu
libéré ouvre un espoir supplémentaire de
développer l'organisation de la
vaccination dans les territoires et je
vous parle en fait ici de l'hôpital
d'arras où j'étais au cours des deux
dernières heures en en point avec
l'ensemble des élus du territoire de
l'artois du bassin minier du douaisis du
ternois et du bal qu'à moi en fait
qu'ils sont les territoires autour
desquels en fait l'hôpital d'arras est
amenée en fait à organiser en quelque
sorte la distribution des doses
ces deux sont arrivés hier ici arras et
le process de vaccination est en marche
les vaccinations se sont bien déroulées
aujourd'hui et et nous avançons et nous
sommes même prêts puisque je suis
président des maires du pas de calais et
je coordonne aussi des associations des
maires de la raison des hôtes des hauts
de france en fait en tant qu'élu à à
mettre les les outils qu'il faut en fait
pour déployer des centres de
vaccinations dont les territoires parce
qu'aujourd'hui en fait c'est ce
qu'attendent nos concitoyens
voilà et mais on ne peut pas en fait
organiser les centres si les vaccins ne
sont pas là ce qui a été dit par le le
porte parole du gouvernement aujourd'hui
et rassurant et correspond à toutes les
discussions en fait très clair que j'ai
pu avoir
y compris avec olivier ferrand que je
s'est engagée sur le sujet et qui je
l'espère en tout cas va nous permettre
dans l'est dans les prochaines semaines
de pouvoir en fait accéléré le mouvement
on sait que de toute façon process de
vaccination est quelque chose qui va
mettre du temps à gérer que ça sert à
rien de raconter des choses qui seraient
qui serait fausse alors organise
vaccination à l'échelle de la france à
l'échelle d'un pays en fait mais du
temps voilà
et on peut pas faire on puisse dire
effectivement un frédéric leturque 1 on
met du temps les chiffres le disent pour
nous c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de
moqueries
voilà sur les réseaux sociaux on entend
certains experts dire que la france est
la risée du monde en tout cas vous
faites partie de ces 250 maires qui ont
proposé de se faire vacciner pour
montrer l'exemple
malgré les pommettes sont on a le
sentiment que la logistique justement
vous en parliez pêche c'est aussi le
sentiment du professeur akon qui était
notre invitée hier soir était de partir
du moment où on a décidé de vacciner
dans les ehpad
on a complètement oublié que dans les
ehpad y avait des personnes qui
n'avaient plus toutes leurs capacités
intellectuelles et que donc il fallait
me prendre contact avec des tuteurs pour
pouvoir obtenir le consentement et ça ça
n'avait pas été anticipée apparemment et
donc effectivement il ya une perte de
temps et là je m'adresse aux
communicants nos benedetti on voit que
le gouvernement voilà mais le mail turbo
si j'ose dire et tente de reprendre la
main il faut préciser quand même que 75%
des français selon un sondage et lab
juge que cette organisation de campagne
de vaccination est très mal gérée par le
gouvernement
il est en train justement de récupérer
main ce gouvernement où ça va mettre du
temps selon vous ça va mettre du temps
mais si vous voulez aujourd'hui
l'exécutif à changer de discours est
vraisembablement également changé de
stratégie parce que tout simplement il y
a eu une pression médiatique politique
et une pression de l'opinion pour que il
change de stratégie je rappelle qu' il y
a encore au moins d'une dizaine de jours
le ministre de la santé olivier vais en
assumer une stratégie de la lenteur
alors il faut c'est qu'il faut expliquer
essayer de comprendre pourquoi cette
stratégie initiale a été déployé alors
elle a peut-être été déployés par ce
qu'il y avait vraisemblablement une
insuffisance logistique
d'ailleurs cette crise sanitaire est en
train de démontrer que l'état
en tout cas au cours à l'épreuve de
cette pandémie apparaît comme un piètre
logisticiens mais aussi parce que il y
avait vraisemblablement de la part des
pouvoirs publics et des autorités
politiques et des autorités sanitaires
la crainte que la défiance qui
aujourd'hui est manifeste comme le
montre un certain nombre d'études
d'appui d'opinion vis-à-vis des sondages
que cette défiance viennent d'une
certaine manière entraver la campagne de
vaccination donc le choix qui a été fait
au niveau du discours qui à mon avis est
une erreur en l'occurrence et
d'intérioriser cette défiance et de
mettre en place ensuite une stratégie
qui était une stratégie initialement
d'un déploiement qui était un
déploiement qui se faisait à petite
vitesse
là en l'occurrence la pression
d'opinions publiques la pression des
médias et la pression politique a
certainement aujourd'hui fait en sorte
que le gouvernement change de fusil des
pour lui entre temps le retard a été
pris et il va être quand même difficile
à rattraper
et la réalité c'est que la comparaison
avec l'ensemble de nos partenaires
européens et d'un d'autres d'autres pays
montrent aujourd'hui que la france est
quand même en retard et on peut se poser
la question si vous voulez s'il ya eu un
véritable retour d'expérience depuis le
début de cette crise on a raté des
masques on n'a pas vraiment réussi les
tests et là en l'occurrence on avait
quand même malgré tout l'expérience de
cet échec et on peut se poser la
question si on s'est mis véritablement
ordre de marche pour démarrer une
campagne de vaccination qui évite en
effet cette controverse supplémentaires
à l'exécutif qu'il en avait pas besoin
dans la gestion de cette crise stéphane
manigold on va évidemment évoqué avec
vous forcément le sort des des
restaurateurs qui seront fixés sur j'ai
envie de dire leur triste sort
certainement demain mais je voudrais
avoir votre opinion de citoyens
justement sur ce vaccin le gouvernement
effectivement vous avez le sentiment
vous aussi il a péché par excès de
prudence pour ne pas heurter pour ne pas
braquer les anti vaccins nombreux en
france
bonsoir je vais pas vous donner mon
opinion de citoyens puisque je porte la
parole d'un collectif qui s'appelle
restons ouverts et je tiens à vous
féliciter arte france parce que vous
avez trouvé le seul homme politique en
france capable de défendre l'idée vers
ans bravo monsieur le maire d'arras ce
beau discours il aimait mes lunaire
olivier ferrand aujourd'hui il est le
responsable
l'unique responsable de la politique de
santé chaotique de ce pays ce pays ça
fait neuf mois qu'il est fermé contat
tonnes quand va reculons que des
entreprises sont massacrés parce que
nous avons un type olivier derand
ministre de la santé qui en charge la
sécurité des français qui la semaine
dernière nous explique avec une
expression d'un autre temps
faut pas confondre vitesse et
précipitation une fois qui s'est pris un
sacré coup de pied au derrière de la
part du président de la république ait
eu raison
ils vivent maintenant va accélérer
monsieur le maire vous avez reçu combien
de vaccins dans votre ville d'arras qui
regroupe quoi 41 mille habitants 0e
combien de vaccins plus décomptés
combien de vaccins vous ai reçu aucun
pourquoi vous pourquoi vous voulez dire
vous avez reçu des vaccins
c'est l'arlésienne nous on a besoin et
cette campagne de vaccination sur
l'efficace et je veux dire une chose
moi je le dis depuis deux jours
maintenant olivier vers ans doit quitter
le gouvernement il n'est plus le général
en chef il ne peut plus être à la tête
de ce pays parce qu'en réalité c'est lui
qui gouverne c'est lui qui dirige et
c'est lui qui nous ferme c'est le code
de santé publique qui lui donne ses
pouvoirs c'est lui qui a le pouvoir de
police
ouvrir 2 fermée de restreindre nos
libertés de tout faire en réalité c'est
lui qui décide de tout et vu qu'il est
incapable et que nous on n'a pas envie
de suivre en général qui ne sait pas
assumer qui n'a pas de colonne
vertébrale parce que nous on est des
chefs d'entreprise et quand on donne un
cap à une entreprise on le maintient on
c'est l'orienter et on est un vrai chef
il n'est pas un chef de guerre il doit
quitter le gouvernement je suis désolé
monsieur le maire je ne suis pas
d'accord avec vous la population dans sa
large majorité n'est pas d'accord avec
vous et franchement venir défendre sur
ce plateau olivier ferrand qui est une
politique catastrophique
c'est insupportable et inaudible et
cette manie de tout de même c'est
justement ce qui est intéressant c'est
de donner la parole à tout le monde et
c'est bien l'essence de notre chaîne
donc on est ravis nous d'entendre toutes
les opinions on va justement laisser la
parole à frédéric leturque un frédéric
leturque c'est justement tout sur veron
ou peut-être aussi on a beaucoup évoqué
ces derniers jours la lourdeur
administrative structurelles un
finalement à notre pays qui pêchent dans
cette affaire écoutez je suis maire
d'arras je suis président d'une
communauté urbaine je suis président
d'une association des maires du
département du pas de calais et je peux
vous dire monsieur contrairement à ce
que vous dites que nous avons su les
vaccins que de la vaccination il en
place 4875 les coups du sort fête 4875
plus en fait
4875 dans la commune de calais qui est
aussi en fait
détenteur d'un hôpital socle pour son
secteur +4 1875 à amiens qui couvre en
fait un autre secteur et je peux vous
dire que le département du pas de calais
aujourd'hui à organiser en fait des
lieux de vaccination pour les personnes
âgées pour les soignants pour les
personnels à risque et que les choses en
fait se met en place
gérer que c'est facile de crier sur un
plateau en fait toute sa colère et je
comprends que vous soyez
finalement en colère monsieur mais ça
fait neuf mois
non monsieur je pense que vous ne
mesurez peut-être pas en fait que le
contexte il n'est pas simplement due en
fait à une personnalité politique mais
il est mondial
que la problématique du coc vide on fait
telle est certainement plus complexes à
traiter en fait que de gérer excuser ou
d'un million de vaccinés en israël plus
de 4 millions aux états unis
c'est bien le chef de guerre qui pilote
la politique de vaccination ce pays moi
je ne suis pas venu en fait t'as tout
télévision pour jouer au tennis je
préside ici un conseil de surveillance
d'hôpital j'ai animé en fait de réunion
juste avant de vous rejoindre ici avec
des soignants avec des gens qui ont
travaillé toute la journée qui ont
organisé les choses qui ont vacciné avec
des présidents de centres hospitaliers
des directeurs en fait qui ont mis en
place les mêmes centres de vaccination
dans le territoire vous avez le droit de
dire en fait que ce que je dis n'est pas
vrai dans tout état de cause en tant que
président de conseil de surveillance
jeudi reconnaître qu'on place voilà dans
une partie tennis ya un arbitre heures
nos vénérés tu y es ce que vous avez
envie de jouer sept arbitres quel est
justement le regard que vous portez sur
voilà la responsabilité éventuellement
du ministre de la santé
ce système évidemment on parle de la
nouvelle ministre hâtive le disais quel
est votre sentiment là-dessus
non mais je ne m'autoriserai surtout pas
être l'arbitré je n'ai pas la prétention
mais en l'occurrence ce qui est vrai
c'est que le sentiment qui se dégage
maintenant depuis encore une fois le
début de cette crise sanitaire et de
manière encore plus forte
j'allais dire avec plus d'acuité avec le
démarrage de cette campagne de
vaccination c'est que on a un état et
une administration qui manque d'agilité
ça a été relevé à plusieurs reprises le
problème le problème c'est que dans une
démocratie ce sont les politiques qui
décident et que si les politiques n'ont
pas pris le pouvoir sur l'administration
c'est qu'il ya manifestement un problème
je rappelle quand même qu emmanuel
macron s'est fait élire sur une promesse
de réformes et notamment de réforme de
l'état en l'occurrence ont ce qu'on
constate on est obligé de constater que
finalement il n'y a rien de nouveau sous
le soleil
on a en france une conception de l'état
sanitaire qui était une conception
d'excellence c'était un de nos derniers
domaines d'excellence et skie vraiment
aujourd'hui choc une partie de l'opinion
publique je veux bien que la comparaison
avec la terre
sonal soit en effet permettre de
relativiser ce qui se passe en france
mais quand on se compare aujourd'hui ne
serait ce que sur le ratio qui à mon
avis le ratio le plus essentiel c'est à
dire le ratio des ces populations
malheureusement on est dans le haut des
pays qui paye le plus lourd tribut à
cette épidémie donc ça veut dire
concrètement qu'il ya quelque chose qui
n'a pas fonctionné
en l'occurrence donc on ne peut pas
totalement absoudre on regarde une
situation qui était ce qui est une
situation internationale la
responsabilité politique de l'exécutif
du ministre de la santé bien évidemment
de son d'administration également mais
aussi du président de la république
parce que je veux bien que le président
de la république et admonesté monsieur v
rang lors du dernier conseil de défense
qui s'est déroulée de l'avant dernier
conseil de défense
mais en l'occurrence sous la vème
république c'est le président de la
république qui est responsable et c'est
lui qui doit s'assurer aussi d'une
certaine manière il nous a dit qu'on
était en guerre qui doit s'assurer en
tant que chef de guerre que la tendance
est à la mesure des moyens étaient à la
mesure notamment de l'épreuve que l'on
travers donc on peut pas si vous voulez
mettre tout sur le dos de
l'administration l'administration et
responsable bien évidemment sur mais le
premier responsable dans un système
politique est un système politique
démocratique c'est le politique et c'est
l'honneur du politique de pouvoir
justement être responsable et de faire
en sorte que l'on puisse répondre à la
crise en tout cas les présidents de
région sont montés au créneau jean
rottner on l'a beaucoup cité qui parlait
d'un scandale d'état précédent dans les
gigantesques hervé morin en normandie
veut acheter ses propres dose de masse
de vaccins xavier bertrand pour la
région les autres transfuges qui fustige
la lenteur vaccinale et le manque de
transparence propose de les écouter il
faut
signer le plus massivement et le plus
rapidement possible je suis en
discussions avec un laboratoire pour
faire en sorte que lorsqu'il y aura plus
de vaccins produits à travers le monde
que nous puissions nous région acheter
des vaccins pour que tous ceux qui vont
bosser le matin puisse être vaccinés
qu'on nous démontre études scientifiques
à l'appui que même avec un protocole
sanitaire renforcée on ne peut pas
rouvrir les restaurants mais alors
pourquoi les cantines scolaires et les
restaurants d'entreprises restent
ouverts ce deux poids deux mesures est
incompréhensible alors là stéphane
manigold xavier bertrand qui met de
l'eau à votre moulin j'imagine bien sûr
les présidents de région ils sont
évidemment choqués par la gestion de et
dans leur grande majorité sont choqués
par cette gestion de crise par cette
espèce de stigmatisation je rappelle
quand même à monsieur le maire d'arras
que les restaurants y compris d'arras
ont fermé depuis trois mois et que le
virus continue à circuler et on parle
même d'une troisième vague qui sera bien
plus importante que la première la
deuxième je vais juste répondre sur la
responsabilité politique
lorsque l'on charge nos fonctionnaires
je suis désolé vous avez deux généraux
aujourd'hui je vais prendre ces exemples
vous avez vers ans et vous avez bruno le
maire veron à la santé catastrophique
mou inexistant bruno le maire offensif
proche des entreprises et sur tous les
terrains avec alain griset sur les pme
l'artisanat et le commerce
donc je suis désolé monsieur le maire de
vous le dire c'est bien une question
politique c'est aux politiques de donner
de l'élan son administration est
certainement pas l'administration qui
doit donner des langues politique c'est
pas comme ça qu'on conçoit une
entreprise en tout cas dans une
entreprise si le chef d'entreprise se
fait donner des ans par ses salariés
c'est qu'un problème et je suis sûr que
dans votre mairie monsieur le maire en
tout cas j'espère c'est vous qui donner
de l'élan au conseil municipal à vos
adjoints et hauts fonctionnaires
municipaux et c'est certainement pas les
fonctionnaires municipaux en tout cas je
l'espère qui vont vous donner de
l'impulsion pour organiser la politique
de vaccination talent que vous venez de
la décrire alors en tout cas ces
politiques ils vont s'exprimer 1 demain
jean castex en tête grande conférence de
presse doit-on s'attendre frédéric
leturque à un nouveau tour de vis est ce
vous en tant que maire justement vous le
souhaitez par nécessité entre guillemets
alors trois choses la première je le
redis pour votre interlocuteur je ne
suis pas là pour faire le procès lit du
président ni du ministre véran ou de
quelques ministres que ce soit moi ce
qui m'intéresse c'est de jouer collectif
c'est de faire mon travail et dans âgées
excusez moi c'est d'engager en fait un
mouvement de travail et d'effort qu'ils
fassent que dans un contexte de guerre
est une priorité en fête nationale on
soit mobilisée et je peux vous dire que
ici dans le territoire
je suis hyper mobilisé y compris auprès
des professions que vous représentez
auprès desquels je suis tous les jours
et on a mis en place des dispositions de
soutien dead et on met en place des
dispositions d'accompagnement et
d'espoir pour la réouverture qui seront
aussi efficace dans ce territoire
qu'ailleurs parce que on se sent tous
concernés par cette situation deuxième
chose oui j'espère en fait qu'il y aura
des des conditions en fait 2-2
d'accélération de cette séquence de
vaccination qui se met en place c'est la
vaccination qui m'intéresse pas des
mesures en fait
j'irai de fermetures supplémentaires qui
viennent en quelque sorte encore
accentué ce côté anxiogène et
désespérant dans lequel en fait on est
placé depuis sept années 2020 donc je
n'attends pas en fait des mesures
supplémentaires de fermeture ou ou des
couvre-feux en fait dans d'autres
départements tout cas c'est parce que
j'espère j'espère plutôt l inverse mais
il est il est clair en fait que
malheureusement des dans un tel contexte
que ce que je vois dans certains
départements de l'est m'attriste et que
je préfère en fait être en mode combat
comme je le suis ici dans le département
du pas de calais pour essayer d'éviter à
ce que quelque part on ne sombre dans ce
type 2
deux sujets et pour répondre à votre
troisième interlocuteur je suis d'accord
avec lui sur un point c'est qu'il faudra
tirer les leçons de ce que l'on vit en
fait depuis le début de l'année 2020
avec cette séquence du coc vide et qu'on
puisse en fait mettre noir sur blanc ce
que l'on a vécu noir sur blanc ce qui a
fonctionné ce qui n'a pas fonctionné
parce que en fait je suis convaincu que
demain on vivra peut-être d'autres
séquences qui seront aussi compliqué et
qu'il faudra qu'on soit en mode combat
un peu plus efficace un peu plus rapide
un peu plus agile un peu plus
opérationnel mais de grâce
essayons de respecter celles et ceux qui
sont debout au travail
je peux vous dire qu'ici je suis
entourée d'hommes et de femmes de
médecins qui donnent le maximum pour
soigner et pour essayer de faire que
nous soyons tous finalement aux
capacités de faire notre travail là où
nous sommes dans le public elle doit
même groupe au monsieur le maire on sait
très bien que les élus locaux
on sait très bien que les élus locaux
les élus de proximité
les maires les présidents de région font
un travail exceptionnel
mes propos c'était pas vous concernant
c'était concernant le ministre vers ans
et pourquoi aujourd'hui nous les
cherchons toujours est-ce qu'on va
donner on va donner allez-y très
rapidement s'il vous plaît parce que le
fait de fixer ses fans manigold le mode
voilà rapidement vous vous terminez
votre propre au hilton le mot de la
farce les mêmes il pas bon la vaccine
pour que la vaccination soit efficace
ces six semaines
il est urgent que le chef de guerre le
général qui s'occupe de la vaccination
soit efficace à l'évidence il ne l'est
pas a renouvellé d'etihad doit à quoi
doit-on s'attendre justement demain en
mode combat comme le disait frédéric
leturque nouveau tour de vis je ne sais
pas s'il faut s'attendre à un nouveau
tour de vis la question est de savoir si
aujourd'hui l'opinion publique est prête
et notamment les acteurs économiques et
je pense aux restaurateurs entre entrée
au milieu culturel centre est
véritablement à supporter encore durant
des semaines et des semaines ce qui
constitue pour eux une catastrophe
économique et sociale
donc en effet on va bien voir en
fonction de la vitesse de circulation du
virus ce qui va être décidé
l'exécutif mais il y a une vraie course
de vitesse aujourd'hui qui est engagée
parce que il y a une profonde lassitude
aujourd'hui qui est en train de
s'exprimer à la fois dans l'opinion
publique et certains noms d'acteurs
économiques sociaux culturels et il est
évident que le déclic qui doit répondre
très rapidement et ne plus disons se
cacher derrière des dysfonctionnements
qui seraient ceux de son administration
en l'occurrence il faut qu'il reprenne
la mer sur son administration qu'il
aille très vite et qui répondent surtout
aux problèmes logistiques parce
qu'aujourd'hui quand même la question
essentielle c'est de savoir est ce que
les doses de vaccins qui sont annoncés
seront bien là dans les jours qui
viennent parce que sur les chiffres
quand même faut-il le rappeler depuis un
certain nombre de semaines on a eu des
annonces qui ont toujours été infirmée
par les ché
merci en tout cas tous les trois
messieurs stéphane manigold frédéric
leturque et arnaud benedetti d'avoir été
avec nous pour eux ce débat ce
décryptage dans quelques instants rester
avec nous nous parlerons des états unis
où il est beaucoup de tension
actuellement autour du congrès où se
déroule la certification des votes qui
devrait lire donc joe biden
le congrès apparemment confinée après
avec une manifestation des pro trump aux
abords du bâtiment et puis direction
londres la justice britannique refuse la
demande de remise en liberté sous
caution déposée par julian assange
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois la france oubliée c'est une
rencontre avec ces citoyens qui ne se
résignent pas à la fatalité
on est comme tout le monde je réponds en
appartement on est énervé on a le
sentiment qu'il faut à chaque fois se
battre ils vivent parfois au bord des
routes nationales pas forcément loin de
paris mais toujours loin de ceux qui les
dirigent
moi je remarque qu'on ait passé un tour
de tracteur etc nous payerons campagne
il faut savoir c'est une vie différente
ils ont le sentiment d'être des français
de seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles bas pourrait t'aider quoi un
peu plus aujourd'hui la france oubliée
c'est montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]
20h30 heure française bienvenue sur rt
france si vous nous rejoignez washington
en ébullition regarder sur ces images on
dirait des milliers partisans de donald
trump sont venus exprimer leur colère
dans la capitale suite aux résultats de
l'élection présidentielle des
manifestants chauffés à blanc par le
discours offensif de leur champion un
peu plus tôt dans la journée il était 17
heures heure française une journée
importante au congrès un congrès qui est
actuellement confiné ses occupants
seraient réfugiés dans les souterrains
c'est la télévision nbc qu'il nous
apporte cette information actuellement
vous le voyez donc sur ces images des
manifestants très en colère alors que se
déroule une certification au congrès
certification qui doit ou devrait donner
la victoire de joe biden le vice
président mike pence a d'ailleurs
annoncé quelques minutes plus tôt dans
une aide qu'il ne s'opposerait pas à
cette certification de la victoire du
candidat démocrate un camouflet pour
donald trump le président avait mis la
pression sur son colistier plus tôt dans
la journée écouter le bus tous ici
présents ne voulons pas voir notre
victoire électorale volés par des
démocrates plein d'audace de la gauche
radicale car c'est ce qu'ils ont fait
est volé par les pseudo médias ce qu'ils
sont en train de faire n'abandonnerons
jamais nous ne procèderons jamais
et j'espère que mike pence fera ce qu'il
faut je l'espère je l'espère parce que
si mike pence fait la bonne chose nous
gagnons l'élection tout ce qu'il a à
faire et cela vient du numéro un où
certainement de l'un des meilleurs
avocats en droit constitutionnel de
notre pays
il a le droit absolu de le faire nous
sommes censés protéger notre pays
soutenir notre pays soutenir notre
constitution et protéger notre
constitution
l instant tout juste d'être un homme qui
dénonce le manque de courage de son
vice-président mais pence alors que je
vous le rappelle grands moments de
tension au congrès où a lieu cette
certification qui devrait donner la
victoire à joe biden vous le voyez sur
ces images en direct
l'épreuve très échauffés en paroles
discours de donald trump qui a eu lieu
trois heures avant donald trump qui ne
veut pas concéder la victoire la défaite
plutôt qu'ils ne concédera jamais cette
défaite dit le président sortant alors
que le congrès est actuellement confiné
ses occupants qui se sont réfugiés dans
les souterrains du bâtiment et cette
question des démocrates américains ont
qu'il remportait la majorité au sénat
d'après plusieurs chaînes de télévision
américaines raphael warnock aurait vécu
la républicaine kelly le flair l'autre
démocrate john au sol revendique à lui
la victoire pour le second siège
le dépouillement se poursuit à l'heure
actuelle joe biden qui espère entamer
son mandat le 20 janvier avec tous les
vié du pouvoir il promet ce soir unités
et actions afin warnock a appelé les
américains à garder espoir
à ce moment de l'histoire américaine
washington a un choix à faire nous avons
tous un choix à faire
allons nous continuer à nous diviser à
nous disperser et à nous faire du tort
où allons nous aimer nos voisins comme
notre propre personne allons-nous jouer
à des jeux politiques alors que des
personnes souffrent ou allons gagner des
combats légitime ensemble et pour en
parler nous sommes avec un claude
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir tondeur maison
merci d'être avec nous les démocrates
qui sont bloc bien parti pour l'emporter
une majorité que signifie cette
potentielle victoire des deux sénateurs
démocrates
ben alors en effet c'est à ces sujets
une surprise en réalité puisque la
géorgie est un état traditionnellement
républicain c'est un état sudiste qui
fut autrefois ségrégationniste et qui
est en principe peu acquis aux
républicains il avait deux sénateurs
républicains
mais il a donné une courte majorité à
joe biden à l'élection présidentielle
résultat que d'ailleurs donald trump que
conteste mais qui a été certifié par
toutes les autorités de l'état de
géorgie qui sont d'ailleurs tout
républicaine
donc il se trouve que les candidats qui
semblent devoir être élus sont deux
démocrates
l'un avec une majorité de 56 % ce qui le
mettrait à l'abri si elle est confirmée
d'un recomptage automatique l'autre
monsieur sauf avec une majorité le
simplement de 50 2% ce qui pourrait
donner lieu à un recomptage
automatique puisque c'est en dessous de
0 5% par rapport aux 50 % donc on va
voir le résultat définitif mais il est
très vraisemblable que tous les deux
vont être élus et en effet ça veut dire
que la sociologie la démographie de
l'état de géorgie a s'est modifiée que
il ya un rajeunissement de la population
que il y à une évolution des vides et
que d'ailleurs atlanta est devenu le
troisième centre de production signol
cinématographique les états unis donc ce
n'est plus le vieux sud
le vieux tubes du vieux sud agricole
c'est un état dynamique et on voit bien
qu'il ya un équilibre maintenant entre
les uns et les autres entre les
républicains et les démocrates
et puis le fait que monsieur trump est
martelée depuis des semaines et des
semaines que cette élection avait été
truqué a peut-être aussi conduit
certains républicains à rester chez eux
puisque l'élection est truqué pourquoi
voter alors toile blanche maison il ya
aussi on en parlait il ya quelques
secondes les fameuses certification des
résultats de la présidentielle qui ont
débuté il ya à peine une heure au
congrès grands moments de tension
puisqu'on le voit au moment où vous nous
parlez que le blanche maison il ya ces
manifestations des supporters preuve
serait même se seraient même introduits
à l'intérieur du capitole le bâtiment et
serait désormais confiné selon la chaîne
nbc ses occupants se serait réfugié dans
les souterrains on peut s'attendre à une
grande journée longue de tensions aux
etats-unis c'était prévisible
j'ai très solide c'est très solide qu'on
soit dans une configuration quasiment
insurrectionnel où des manifestants
prennent d'assaut ou votre tente de
prendre d'assaut le capital ils n'y
arriveront sans doute heureusement pas
mais encouragée par le président sortant
c'est une situation probablement sans
précédent en tout cas aux états unis
alors effectivement
la constitution prévoit que des
sénateurs ou des membres de la chambre
des représentants peuvent objecté aux
résultats qui arrivent certifié par
chacun des états puisque les états unis
étant très décentralisé fait chacun des
états fédérés qui certifie le résultat
de l'élection est en réalité cela
certification avec les deux chambres
réunies convoquons en congrès c'est en
jeu en réalité une formalité
d'ailleurs le président là monsieur
nixon riche président à l'époque a
présidé un exercice de ce genre où il a
certifié parce qu'il n'avait pas le
choix
l'élection de son principal rival et est
arrivé la même chose monsieur al gore
qu'un certain nombre d'années plus tard
et par conséquent monsieur baydan va
suivre le même cours des choses et ne
s'opposera pas à la certification
il l'a dit publiquement il a répété tout
à l'heure mais de toute façon le
vice-président américain est évidemment
respecte la constitution et en plus il
est soucieux de son avenir politique on
dit parfois qu'il pourrait être candidat
à la prochaine élection
et naturellement il va suivre le cours
ces objections par un membre du sénat où
un membre de la chambre des
représentants conduisent à une
suspension de séance et chacune des
chambres se réunissent séparément pour
étudier l'objection qu'a fait un de ses
membres est bien un débat qui peut durer
jusqu'à deux heures suivi d'un vote
le résultat ne fait aucun doute mais
comme vous l'avez dit docteur ça va
durer probablement toute la journée
peut-être toute la nuit ça des vins
dépendre du nombre d'objections qui
seront soulevés pour le moment c'est un
représentant de l'arizona et un sénateur
de l'arizona qui ont soulevé par écrit
une objection qui normalement devrait
être en cours d'examen s'il n'y avait
pas ce confinement due à la situation de
la manifestation sur les marches du
capitole chose est sûre en tout cas tu
le manges maison c'est que pour le
moment à la séance a été interrompue
après
réellement une irruption d certains
manifestations pro trump dans le
bâtiment du capitole
à tel point d'ailleurs que le maire de
washington vient d'imposer la 12e tomber
un couvre-feu à partir de 18 heures dans
la capitale américaine
sans doute des manifestants est chaude
et chauffé à bloc par le discours de
leur champion c'était à 17 heures heure
française donald trump qui a tout de
même affirmé qu'il ne conseillerait
jamais la défaite assez étonnant quand
même de la part d'un président de la
plus grande démocratie du monde comme il
se présente même
oui c'est très étonnant il a réaffirmé
sur tous les tons nous ne considérons
pas cette défaite on m'a volé ma
réélection
c'est ce qu'il a dit devant ces
manifestants à 6 heures de l'après midi
heure locale de washington
donc c'est en effet une situation de
blocage assez grave
que peut faire le président donald trump
pendant les deux semaines qui est lui
reste à exercer ses pouvoirs la maison
blanche
eh bien on en a un exemple ce soir il
peut en effet provoquer des désordres
pour empêcher le cours normal d'une
transition menant à l'installation de
joe biden mais il va surtout lutter pour
garder le leadership son leadership sur
le parti républicain
le parti républicain qui est divisée
parce qu' un certain nombre de
responsables républicains
et puis les institutions qui les
soutiennent les chambres de commerce par
exemple se sont prononcés pour dire il
faut arrêter ça tout de suite parce que
nous avons besoin de garder nos chances
pour un candidat républicain dans quatre
ans et dans les élections de 2024 et par
conséquent nous devons respecter les
institutions en plus pour des raisons
qui tiennent à l'ordre public au
fonctionnement de l'économie en période
de vide par dessus le marché
évidemment il n'est pas très opportun de
déclencher ce genre de contestation
radicale
donc le président trump est en
difficulté et il veut garder le
leadership sur le parti républicain la
situation est grave elle peut mener
d'ailleurs à une scission du parti
républicain qui serait issue extrême que
naturellement les responsables de ce
parti vont essayer d'éviter
et puis le président moment et reste le
chef des armées et on a vu cette lettre
extraordinaire il y a quelques jours de
cinq précédents ministre de la défense
secrétaire à la défense aux états unis
qui quel que soit leur parti ont signé
une lettre pour dire qu'il fallait
surtout pas mais les larmes et l'armée
des états unis d'amérique à la solution
d'un problème politique qui était le
résultat d'une élection
l'armée n'avait rien à voir rien à faire
avec ça les institutions devaient
fonctionner normalement pour décider qui
était élu président des états unis
et effectivement si cinq anciens munis
de la défense ont fait cette lettre
c'est probablement que le problème se
posait et on a su en effet que dans
certaines réunions à la maison blanche
le président des états unis à poser les
questions qui pouvaient impliquer
l'entrée en jeu de l'armée soit en
utilisant la loi martiale dans certaines
zones dans certains états soit en
décidant de frappes ponctuelles dans
certaines zones sensibles comme l'iran
sur des installations nucléaires et bien
entendu les chefs militaires et lémance
majorité de ses conseillers ils en ont
dissuadés
il reste deux semaines qui sont deux
semaines qui vont être délicates qui
vont être dangereuse parce que donald
trump ne renoncera pas et il n'assistera
probablement pas à la séance du 20
janvier d'installation de son successeur
peut-être sera-t-il ce jour là sur son
terrain de golf
merci beaucoup claude manche maison
expert en relations internationales
on va revenir sur ces images en direct
devant le capitole capitole où il ya eu
une interruption de séance au congrès où
se déroule en ce moment la certification
qui devait donner la victoire donc à joe
biden certification des résultats de la
présidentielle des manifestants au trump
se serait littéralement introduit dans
le capitole où se réunit donc le congrès
le bâtiment serait désormais confiné
selon la chaîne nbc ses occupants se
serait réfugié dans les souterrains sont
donc le capitole après que des
supporters de donald trump se serait
donc introduits dans le bâtiment le
maire de washington impose un couvre-feu
à 18 heures dans la ville
à l'instant donald trump ce poste
un tweet veuillez soutenir notre police
du capitole et notre application d'un
droit ils sont vraiment du côté de notre
pays
rester en paix voici pour les derniers
développements ce grand moment de
tension et ces images un petit peu
surréaliste il faut bien lire de ce
capitole envahis par les manifestants de
donald trump donald trump qui on le
rappelle a donné un discours à il y a
trois heures à 17 heures heure française
le président sortant qui a affirmé
qu'ils le concéderez jamais la défaite
certainement que ces manifestants
étaient donc chauffé à blanc par ses
discours très offensif de leur champion
qui ne souhaitent pas concédé la défaite
on viendra évidemment sur ces événements
aux états unis dans les prochaines
minutes et toujours aux états unis pas
de poursuites judiciaires contre le
policier auteur de sept tirs par balles
dans le dos de jacob blake est le 23
août dernier
une affaire qui avait provoqué trois
nuits d'émeutes au nord de chicago à la
veille de cette annonce l'état d'urgence
avait été déclaré dans toute la ville
florian vers une décision de justice
controversée
une de plus aux états unis plus de
quatre mois après le déclenchement de ce
qu'on nomme désormais la sphère jacob
black le procureur de kenosha annonce
qu'aucune charge ne sera retenue contre
les policiers impliqués
c'est ma décision que j'annonce à
présent devant vous qu'aucun agent de
qeynos chan sera inculpé dans cette
affaire ne sera accusée d'une quelconque
infraction pénale
sur la base des faits et de la loi nous
avons décidé qu'aucun chef d'inculpation
ne serait retenue aucune poursuite
y compris pour le policier qui avait
tiré à sept reprises dans le dos de
jacob black le 23 août dernier
aujourd'hui paralysé la fois américain
de 29 ans est devenu malgré lui l'un des
symboles des violences policières aux
états unis selon le procureur général le
policier concerné a eu face à jacob
blake un comportement non pénalement
répréhensible par la loi
anticipant un tel choix de la part du
magistrat
cette petite ville du nord de chicago
avait dès ce lundi soir déclaré l'état
d'urgence
une décision qui a évidemment fait
réagir l'avocat et la famille de jaco
blake mais également plusieurs grandes
figures de la communauté afro américaine
jacob est très déçu vous savez comment
vous réagiriez si vous étiez paralysé en
ayant reçu cette balle dans le dos n'a
jamais voulu faire de mal à qui que ce
soit il voulait juste s'en aller ça
dépasse ce pauvre jacobs tout ça le
dépasse complètement
ça concerne toutes ces absurdités c'est
pour ça que les gens sortent et nous
supporte vous savez pourquoi
car ça pourrait être le à la place de
jacob entendre ce qu'il s'est passé à
kenosha est un déchirement voir et
entendre toutes ses affaires depuis
tellement longtemps pas seulement envers
la communauté noire mais aussi envers la
communauté blanche de ce pays
c'est un coup de poignard est un
déchirement peu après les faits les
policiers impliqués avaient seulement
été suspendus de leurs fonctions
la sphère jacquot blake avait notamment
contribué à relancer le mouvement black
lise matters un mouvement qui pourrait
bien à la suite de cette nouvelle
décision polémique pousser ses militants
investir les rues de plusieurs villes
américaines
mais julian assange reste en prison
déception pour ces soutiens qui avait
remporté une première victoire lundi la
justice britannique avait alors refusé
d'extrader le fondateur de wikileaks
vers les états unis
l'australien de 49 ans est emprisonné
depuis le mois d'avril 2010 9 au royaume
uni le récit de thé au combat la
nouvelle année qui commence pourrait
bien ressembler aux précédentes pour
julian assange
la justice britannique vient de refuser
sa demande de mise en liberté et décide
donc de le maintenir en détention
une décision motivée par le risque de
fuite de l'accusé sont la juge
vanessa par ailleurs poursuivi par les
états unis pour la diffusion massive de
documents confidentiels
le fondateur de wikileaks est incarcéré
depuis plus d'un an et demi au royaume
uni une véritable injustice selon fidel
narvaez ex-consul de l'équateur à
londres et proche du journaliste de 49
ans
tétouan cette chasse t il n'a rien à
répondre à la justice dans sa position
actuelle
pourquoi est il maintenu en prison ayhan
donc je comprends que ce n'est pas la
fin du jeu pas la fin du chemin il y
aura un appel pour la décision
d'aujourd'hui et nous espérons que cet
appel sera suivie d'un plus grand sens
de la justice
si la défense du journaliste ne souhaite
pas baisser les bras
l'état de santé de l'australien pose
question alors qu'il doit retourner à la
prison de haute sécurité de belmarsh
julien assange avait pourtant vu naître
une lueur d'espoir en début de semaine
le refus de la justice britannique de
l'extrader vers les états unis avait été
accueilli par ses proches avec beaucoup
de soulagement puisqu'ils y risque 175
ans de prison une décision positive à
son égard qui n'a pas été suivie d'effet
très affecté l'avocate stella maurice
demande au président américain de
gracier son compagnon
c'est une grande déception julian ne
devrait pas être à la prison de belles
marches en premier lieu je demande au
département de la justice d'annuler les
charges et au président des états unis
de grâce et julian
des tourments qui ne semble pas près de
prendre fin en effet les états unis ont
d'ores et déjà fait appel de la décision
de justice britannique refuse ans son
extradition vers washington
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
françois cambert délégué général de
l'association robin des doigts bonsoir
ans maintenant vers merci d'être avec
nous la justice qui refusons des strade
mais qui gardent en prison julien
assange
qu'est ce que ça dit selon vous je crois
qu'on est tous d'accord tous ceux qui en
france en tout cas et soutiennent le
blaco de la scène c'est complètement
incohérent parce que dans la mesure où
la logique judiciaire n'est pas
respectée on la juge en le considère que
ya pas matière à l'extrader et en même
temps elle le garde en détention
je précise qu'en france d'ailleurs ça ne
serait pas possible parce que on
distinguerait depuis quelques années le
juge qui poursuit ou qui par le juge
d'instruction et qu'on a inventé il ya
10-15 ans qui est le juge des libertés
et de la détention qui n'est pas le même
donc là on a une espèce d incohérence
puisque d'un côté elle explique que l
l'expédient pas aux états unis et on est
évidemment ravi parce que pour des
raisons de santé pourraient pas soutenir
la détention là bas mais en même temps
elle le laisse dans une prison qui est à
peu près l'équivalent de certaines
prisons américaines c'est quand même une
prison de haute sécurité où il n'a rien
à faire de toute manière qui est une
prison très difficile il est en
détention depuis maintenant un an et
demi il a passé faut pas l'oublier dans
l'ambassade des années terribles à
savoir tous les matins à s'il allait
être remis ou pas aux américains
c'est une situation psychologiquement
très difficile donc il ya une
incohérence absolue qui est très
étonnante
bon il faut savoir gré du voir la
dépêche tout à l'heure que les avocats
anglais font appel de la décision donc
de cette décision de maintien en
détention
j'ai pas la date précise mais
on espère que ce sera assez vite puisque
il ya à l'évidence en tout cas peut-être
un embarras mais une stratégie de le
laisser c'est une stratégie possible de
le laisser mourir en prison c'est ce que
nous en redoutent depuis très longtemps
ça a été très long à venir cette
audience
et ça risque d'être encore très long
jusqu'à ce que la cour d'appel à la cour
en angleterre examine son appel donc le
bon sens et l'honnêteté juridique
logique c'est de dire laisser le libre
il a il a deux petits enfants il a une
heure il a son épouse à s'échapper
bon enfin on n'imagine pas assange en
angleterre aujourd'hui libre s'échapper
parce que il y là il aura envie de se
défendre enfin je ne pense pas pas
savoir ce qui se passe dans sa tête mais
c'est complètement incohérent sur le
plan simplement du droit et de la
logique juridique c'est ce que tous les
gens alors on est content évidemment que
ce soit un avis défavorable à
l'extradition
même s'il est juridiquement pas très
très structuré il a fallu attendre la
dernière page du jugement pour que pour
savoir quel que la juge ne l'enverrai
pas aux états unis en l'état mais un
appel des américains donc pour l'instant
on est dans cette situation assez
bizarre où il est maintenu en détention
ce qui est pas cohérent du tout qui est
pas logique
alors je parle pas du côté militant
évidemment il n'a rien à faire en prison
mais ça c'est un point de vue militant
un personnel que du point de vue de
juristes c'est pas cohérent et on espère
que la cour d'appel jeudi la cour
d'appel
highco va statuer rapidement le plus
rapidement possible et va le libérer
éventuellement sous caution c'est ce
qu'on fait ce après midi les avocats
anglais
même si les poursuites demeure et c'est
loin d'être fini évidemment puisque on
ne sait pas quand aura lieu le procès en
appel
on ne sait pas ce que vont faire les
américains ou pas enfin ils ont pas
l'air de vouloir abandonner la partie
nulle part vous pas non plus trop rêver
sur le nouveau président sur on l'espère
aussi
donc nous nous nous maintenons notre
position depuis des mois et des mois qui
est celle de beaucoup de confort une
sorte de collectif informel de gens qui
sont actifs en france pour défendre
assange qui est de dire l'asile
politique parce que on est intraitable
là dessus je rappelle que
on le demande depuis des mois je
rappelle que celui qui était l'avocat
d'assange mais qui est pas resté très
longtemps c'est à dire le ministre de la
justice avait annoncé corée a créé il ya
dix huit mois qu'il allait demander
l'asile
on en a plus entendu parler nous avons
sollicité des députés et on continue à
le faire et tous ceux qui peuvent nous
d'écouter sont invités à le faire
déposer des questions écrites on a
obtenu que jean lassalle dépôt d'une
question orale
on a vu tous il ya trois mois à la
réponse misérable du ministre le drian
qui a expliqué que hassan je n'étais pas
en danger que tout allait très bien pour
lui bon maintenant on peut considérer ça
puisque il est pas en danger la famille
dans une prison de haute sécurité il est
en mauvaise santé et ya aucune raison de
le maintenir dans cette prison donc
première chose il faut le libérer et si
la france veut bien se rappeler qu'elle
est la france il faut lui offrir l'asile
et ça personne ne l'a vraiment
officiellement demandé à monsieur macron
qui s'est abrité derrière monsieur le
drian qui était assez misérable à
l'assemblée assez médiocre en lisant des
fiches donc plus que jamais nous
demandons au président de la république
français d'accorder l'asile
ce qui paraît de bon sens parce qu'il
serait très difficile aux anglais de
refuser je rappelle quand même et c'est
il faut le saluer que le président du
mexique
dès lundi a offert l'asile a proposé
l'asile au mexique
il a été un des jeunes et à s'engager
très tôt en faveur de l'asile pour la
salle nous c'est une hypothèse puisque
un singe le souhaitent ils l'avaient
fait dire à plusieurs reprises il avait
fait dire cette année par dupont moretti
l'asile pour être parfaitement cohérent
il y avait qu en france il a un enfant
majeur qui est en france qui est pas
vieux
ça serait élégant et ça serait bien
qu'est ce qui fait que dupont moretti a
trahi un point de vue l'a trahi il a une
parle plutôt de l'asile maintenant qu'il
est ministre
donc nous continuons par des pétitions
par des appels aux députés français et
au sénateur a demandé l'asile plus que
jamais parce que ça peut être une façon
de le faire sortir
on soutient évidemment et on espère
qu'il va être remis en liberté on
appelle dans les jours qui viennent le
plus vite possible même si on n'a pas ce
soit la date est bien sûr on espère un
arrêt des poursuites mais il faut pas
trop rêver dans l'immédiat il faut
qu'ils puissent continuer à se défendre
à l'ombre libre avec en étant une des
conditions de défense normal on pourra
voir ses avocats n'étant pas dans ce
cachot de haute sécurité
parce que là encore une fois la logique
nous échappe complètement
on nous dit on refuse de l'extrader aux
états unis parce qu'ils seraient dans
des conditions absolument insupportable
psychologiquement et c'est vrai si marcy
pardonnez moi on arrive à la fin de
notre temps en tout cas on a compris
évidemment votre message que la france
pourrait jouer un rôle à dans cette
affaire pour faire sortir éventuellement
avec une demande d'asile
je viens assange merci beaucoup à vous
françois cambert délégué général de
l'association robin des lois merci à
vous restez avec nous dans quelques
instants nous reviendrons sur ces
tensions aux états unis les manifestants
pro tome qui ont fait irruption au
capitole le bâtiment qui serait selon la
chaîne nbc
confiné ses occupants se serait réfugié
dans les couloirs du congrès juste donc
en dessous de ceux capitole qui vous le
voyez sur ces images en direct est
cernée par les manifestants pro trump
est resté avec nous
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
on est comme je mesure n'est pas en
appartement on est énervé dans l
sentiment qu'il faut à chaque fois se
battre ils vivent parfois au bord des
routes nationales pas forcément loin de
paris mais toujours loin de ceux qui les
dirigent
moi je vois des remarques ont il passe
un tour de tracteur et cnooc une
campagne il faut savoir c'est une vie
différente
ils ont le sentiment d'être des français
de seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles ma forêt td quoi un peu plus
aujourd'hui la france oubliée c'est
montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]
l'état islamique a recruté dans toutes
les couches de la société sans faire de
tri des mineurs des femmes des
délinquants des criminels de droit
commun tout le monde est venu à jaca en
syrie il ya encore quelques quelques
années au moment de charlie hebdo
clou du bataclan il y avait un état
islamiste qui semblait diriger tout ça
la bascule et se fait justement en 2015
et smith est un peu le passage de relais
d'al qaïda l'état islamique quelque part
dans notre politique internationale est
bien évident qu'il faut pas créer les
conditions à nouveau une terre de jihad
et de cet appel d'air justement où en
recrutement l'a malheureusement faire en
syrie en irak
[Musique]
21h heure française sous il est bienvenu
pour cette deuxième heure d'émission
tout de suite voici les titres de
l'actualité de ce mercredi 6 janvier
interruption surprise de séance au
congrès après l'irruption au capitole de
manifestants pro trump alors que se
dérouler les débats pour la
certification de la victoire de joe
biden le bâtiment serait confinée et ses
occupants se serait réfugié dans les
souterrains du congrès selon la chaîne
américaine nbc
le vice président mike pence annonce
qu'il ne s'opposera pas à cette
certification au grand dam de donald
trump qui affirme que le vice-président
manque de courage
[Musique]
la crise sanitaire et la flambée des
quatre co vide nouveau record de
contamination aux etats-unis tout comme
au portugal et au royaume uni
le confinement une solution privilégiée
par plusieurs pays en attendant que les
campagnes de vaccination offre une
immunité collective suffisante pour un
retour à la normale le vaccin de modern
a été approuvé aujourd'hui par l'agencé
européenne des médicaments et par
bruxelles les contestations à la laïcité
en hausse dans les établissements
scolaires en france est ce que révèle
une étude publiée ce mercredi par l'ifop
plus de quatre enseignants sur dix
disent s'être déjà auto censurer afin
d'éviter d'éventuels incidents avec des
élèves une enquête ci intervient près de
trois mois après l'assassinât du
professeur samuel pâtit
[Musique]
mais ce coup théâtre à washington en ce
moment même vous allez le voir sur ces
images en direct la séance de
certification de la victoire de joe
biden comme président des états unis a
été suspendu il y à quelques minutes
seulement
plusieurs manifestants des centaines
même en fait irruption au congrès
remisant à l'évacuation du bâtiment
signe de l'extrême tension sur place le
maire de washington a décrété un
couvre-feu à partir de 18h heure locale
de son côté le président américain vient
d'appeler ses partisans à éviter les
violences
pourtant quelques heures plus tôt il
avait tenu un discours très offensif le
président sortant avait mis la pression
sur son vice président mike pence
plus tôt dans la journée donc pour ne
pas proclamer joe biden vainqueur je
vous propose d'écouter donald trump du
tous ici présents ne voulons pas voir
notre victoire électorale volés par des
démocrates plein d'audace de la gauche
radicale car c'est ce qu'ils ont fait
est volé par les pseudo médias ce qu'ils
sont en train de faire n'abandonnerons
jamais nous ne concédons renonce jamais
[Applaudissements]
et j'espère que mike pence fera ce qu'il
faut je l'espère je l'espère parce que
si mike pence serait la bonne chose nous
gagnons l'élection tout ce qu'il a à
faire et cela vient du numéro un où
certainement de l'un des meilleurs
avocats en droit constitutionnel de
notre pays
il a le droit absolu de le faire nous
sommes censés protéger notre pays
soutenir notre pays soutenir notre
constitution et protéger notre
constitution
et voilà quelques heures donc après ce
discours là qui a eu lieu à 17 heures
heure française grands moments de
tension aux abords du capitole qui a été
envahie par des milliers de manifestants
pro trump qui ont donc envahi cette
colline du capitole plongeant dans la
confusion la session du congrès qui
devait confirmer la victoire de joe
biden à l'élection présidentielle du 3
novembre des manifestants qui ont fait
irruption lors des débats de la chambre
des représentants s'est quasiment
peut-être du jamais vu ils ont investi
les terrasses du capitole et provoqué
l'évacuation des bâtiments du congrès
peu après justement que le vice
président mike pence suite annoncé qu'il
ne pourrait pas s'opposer à la
certification de la victoire de joe
biden c'est notre chambre
reprenons la chance et notre parlement a
déclaré à l'agencé pense passe un
manifestant anonyme grands moments de
tension dont en ce moment même dans la
capitale américaine washington avec vous
le voyez sur ces images assez
impressionnante des milliers de
manifestants pro tom venu apporter
or soutient donc à leur champion donald
trump enel trump qui a d'ailleurs
affirmé qu'il ne céderait jamais qu'il
n'admettrait jamais sa défaite à
l'élection présidentielle du 3 novembre
nous reviendrons évidemment très
longuement à la fin de cette heure avec
notre invité gérald olivier spécialiste
des états unis sur ces événements qui se
déroulent en ce moment même vous le
voyez en direct sur ces images à
washington alors que la certification
devait se tenir la certification des
résultats la présidentielle devait se
tenir pendant toute la journée au
congrès des états unis et dans
l'actualité également évidemment le
monde frappé de plein fouet par la crise
sanitaire du cornet virus on dénombre
sur la planète plus de 87 millions 2,4
qu'ovide 19 et 1,8 million de décès une
troisième vague qui n'épargne pas la
corée du nord le pays renforce les
règles de distanciation le japon lui
ferme ses frontières aux étrangers non
résidents jusqu'à fin janvier 2021 tokyo
envisage d'entrer en état d'urgence
aux etats-unis le nombre de nouveaux cas
de contamination atteint un triste
record avec 240 mille huit cent huit
personnes recensées en 24 heures et puis
au brésil le nombre de cas et de décès
continue d'augmenter également
l'économie à du pays subit également de
très lourdes conséquences économiques de
la crise sanitaire à tel point que son
président andré erbol sonar haut déclare
le brésil en faillite
les détails avec mes disques et fit une
ville en état d'urgence sanitaire pour
les cinq prochains mois
c'est le triste résultat de la
recrudescence des cas de coronavirus
dans cette région du brésil à manaus la
plupart des commerces voient leur
activité réduite
seule exception quelques magasins
vendant des produits de première
cité provoquant de longues files
d'attentes les manifestations publiques
elles sont annulés au moins jusqu'au
mois de mars
nous avons dû déclarer l'état d'urgence
pour nous donner une capacité meilleures
et plus rapides à mettre en oeuvre les
mesures nécessaires par exemple nous
travaillons sur la possibilité d'obtenir
des vaccins d'une entreprise privée ce
qui ferait de nous la première
municipalité du brésil à distribuer des
vaccins à voir si manaus symbole
malheureux d'un brésil fortement touché
par la pandémie
une situation critique qui a poussé jam
hole sun araw à faire une déclaration
inquiétante
le président brésilien affirme que le
pays est en faillite et impute cet
effondrement économique aux restrictions
mises en place pour lutter contre le coc
vite 19 le brésil est en faillite je ne
peux rien faire je voulais changer la
grille de réduction des impôts mais il
ya eu ce virus alimenté par la presse
que nous avons ici
cette presse sans intérêt une crise qui
pourrait s'aggraver en ce début d'année
2021 en raison des rassemblements qui
ont eu lieu lors des fêtes de fin
d'année les chiffres liés à la pandémie
risque d'augmenter encore au brésil au
cours des prochaines semaines
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis le brésil avec marie-christine
duniaud médecin généraliste au consulat
français de rio de janeiro c'est notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir marie-christine duniaud merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors en tant que médecin parce que vous
n'êtes évidemment pas analyse politique
comment vous réagissez à cette
déclaration de jayen ball sonar
aujourd'hui c'est catastrophique parce
que en réalité c'est la réalité
c'est vraiment ce qui se passe ici au
brésil on a complètement perdu
absolument les règnes de l'épidémie on
n'arrive plus à rien faire les hôpitaux
sont saturés le service public aussi
bien que le service privé est
complètement saturé il ya une moyenne
d'occupation de l'ide de soins intensifs
qui tourne entre 95 et 100 %
d'occupation complète
il manque énormément du personnel lui
manque énormément de soignants bien sûr
il manque beaucoup de lits de
réanimation mais pas seulement de lits
dans les services de réanimation mais de
lits dans les hôpitaux d'une façon
générale on a jusqu'à présent on arrive
à 198 milles morts ce qui est énorme
le plus terrible ce que ce sont les
chiffres officiels les chiffres
officieux on ne connaît pas on n'a pas
les moyens de les connaître c'est ça qui
est ça qui est terrible
on a une moyenne de ces derniers jours
on avait une moyenne de 57 milk à
nouveau par jour c'est pareil tout est
très peu on n'a pas les moyens
testez surtout dans le service public
les services privés ites davantage ça
c'est tout à fait normal
ils ont plus de moyens mais les services
publics test très peu et quand il teste
on a les résultats dans disons 12 15
jours voire 20 jours
donc ces déchets sont des chiffres qui
sont absolument en dessous de la réalité
nous ce qu'on voit aux magazines dire
que ce qui semble incroyable c'est que
gerba le sonar ou quand il déclare comme
ça le brésil en faillite cet après midi
il dit je ne peux rien faire
attribuant cette crise a à ce virus le
site alimenté par la presse ça paraît
incroyable ce qu'il croise et il dit
je ne sais pas si le crois je pense
qu'il le croit parce que c'est quelqu'un
qui n'est pas très sérieux disons au
minimum est en réalité le brésil avait
déjà un déficit budgétaire énorme avant
avant qu'il n'arrive qui s'est aggravée
lors de la première année lors de
l'année 2018
et puis boum à la crise en 2019 qui a
commencé la crise monétaire qui a
commencé à vraiment faire la montre et a
montré sa son vrai visage en 2019 bon ça
s'est aggravé en 2020 c'est à cause du
virus mais c'est pas à cause du virus
que le brésil est en faillite
alors on se souvient avant les fêtes un
des images de la plage de coquets
copacabana noire de monde on connaît
évidemment aux états unis les fefans
divine
est ce que le pain le pire est encore à
venir au brésil
oui tout simplement parce qu'il n'y a
pas de véritable confinement même quand
les autorités déterminer des exige qu'il
ya un confinement ya pas de confinement
les gens continuent à aller à la plage
les gens continuent ils ont fait la fête
pendant qu'il mois de décembre et
continue à la faire ça c'est terrible
les plages bondées de monde les gens se
se s'agglomèrent n'importe où dans l'est
dans les transports en commun etc
donc ya pas de confinement bien souvent
un garçonnet moi madame comment vous
vous l'expliquer parce que c'est vrai
qu'il ya vous l'avez dit vous les avez
cités ces morts au brésil ça veut dire
que la population n'a pas conscience
finalement de la dangerosité de ce virus
au brésil et une grande
il ya une grande partie de la population
qui n'a pas continent qui n'a absolument
pas confiance qui n'y croient pas qu'il
ne veut pas y croire et une autre partie
de cette population qui ne peut pas
faire autrement que de travailler mais
même comme ça c'est pas c'est pas c'est
pas obligé qu'elle respecte les gestes
barrières bien souvent elles ne les
respectent pas non plus donc il ya eu un
manque de conscience de la part de la de
la majorité de la population je dirais
alors évidemment le brésil et le vaccin
qui semblerait aussi être la seule
solution la cour suprême a d'ailleurs
rendu la vaccination obligatoire avec
des sanctions pour les réfractaires mais
il semblerait que chez vous au brésil il
est également bon coup de retard on n'a
pas franchement commencer à vacciner
n'est ce pas absolument pas absolument
pas c'est toucher d'un coup il ya des
tas de négociations qui sont toujours en
cours en plus de ça depuis hier on sait
qu'il manque énormément de matériel pour
vacciner
pas seulement les vaccins bien sûr
puisque les négociations continuent à
être en cours mais il manque aussi du
matériel n'y a pas de lien pas assez de
seringue a pas assez d'aiguillés enfin
gardien c'est c'est dramatique et on
imagine que justement le président
brésilien dont on parlait n'arrange pas
les choses puisque lui il se présente
sans complexe comme anti vaccin avec des
propos assez étonnant d'ailleurs sur sur
le vaccin
oui oui tout à fait il a dit que si c
est vacciné il ressemblerait un
crocodile ou un truc comme ça je vous
rappelle que les lauréats des crocodiles
et les hommes auraient des voix de
femmes at il dit jayen rossonero sur le
vexin on imagine que ça n'arrange pas
les choses pour promouvoir cette
campagne future de vaccination d'un an
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui vont
être contre le vaccin tout simplement
parce qu'ils vont avoir peur ça faut
reconnaître que c'est la réalité un
petit peu partout dans le monde on sait
pas seulement spécifique au brésil mais
en plus de ça il ya comme n'aura pas
beaucoup de vaccins
il ya quand même deux cent vingt
millions d'habitants mais ce brésil du
les les
les prix des vaccins même le astrazeneca
qui s'est le moins cher de tous a vu les
prix des vaccins
il est impossible qu'on vaccine 200
millions de personnes
ça c'est impossible faut reconnaître que
ça va pas ça va pas aider ça pourra pas
se taire en plus de ça je crois que les
gens ils vont ils vont les gens qui ont
une certaine c'est des moyens dit
des gens qui à partir d'une classe
moyenne et moyenne supérieure ils vont
se faire vacciner seront les moyens même
de se faire vacciner dans le privé mais
par contre dans le service public on y
aura chez pas 1% de la population qui va
se faire vacciner
celle ci merci en tout cas marie
christine du nude avoir été avec nos
médecins généralistes au consulat
français de rio de janeiro
merci de nous avoir expliqué la
situation inquiétante au brésil ab
retour en europe à présent le vieux
continent qui serre la vis entre
confinement et restrictions le portugal
enregistrent 10000 infections en 24
heures un record alors que la pression
sur les hôpitaux s'accentue du côté de
l'irlande les écoles ferment au moins
jusqu'à la fin du mois de janvier en
attendant que les campagnes de
vaccination offre une immunité
collective suffisante ou un retour à la
normale les pays bas ont d'ailleurs
décidé d'avancer de deux jours le début
de la vaccination dernier pays de l'ue à
se lancer dans cette campagne et
l'allemagne de son côté et dont les
autorités essuie les critiques 1 pour
une campagne de vaccination jugée trop
lente et bien l'allemagne prolonge
également les restrictions jusqu'au 31
janvier au moins les précisions de peter
olivier notre correspondant berthet à
berlin angela merkel et les dirigeants
des 16 états allemands sont parvenus à
un accord si l'on peut dire
mardi pour prolonger le confinement les
écoles les salles de sport les commerces
non essentiels resteront fermés jusqu'à
fin janvier de nouvelles mesures
s'ajoutent également à celles déjà
adoptées concernant les contacts en
dehors du foyer
on ne peut désormais rencontrés qu'une
seule autre personne venant d'un autre
foyer de plus et dans les régions où les
nouvelles contaminations des passes de
son pour cent mille personnes
les déplacements seront restreints à 15
km du domicile au gué la merkel a
déclaré mardi
après avoir trouvé cet accord avec les
chefs de région que ces nouvelles
mesures étaient nécessaires
certains épidémiologistes demandé des
mesures plus strictes mais le consensus
est très fragile entre le gouvernement
fédéral et et les dirigeants des régions
l'accord était à peine trouvé que le
gouvernement de la basse-saxe
déclaraient qu'ils n'appliqueraient pas
les restrictions de déplacement des
responsables du bad vinterberg ont
déclaré qu'ils allaient étudier le
problème mais qui n'étaient pas enclins
à restreindre le déplacement dans leur
région en mecklembourg poméranie
occidentale
ils disent vouloir garder les écoles
ouvertes donc il n'y a pas encore de
véritable entente sur la gestion de la
situation
un consensus se retrouve chez les
manifestants qui continuent à protester
contre les mesures de confinement
le week-end dernier à nuremberg la
police anti émeute a dû intervenir et
bien beau défendu le programme de
vaccination ce mardi dont la lenteur et
critiquer tout cette semaine le ministre
de la santé games pam avait déclaré que
totalement souhaitant se faire vacciner
devrait les pouvoirs ici en gros cet été
pour angela merkel
le déploiement avance à la bonne vitesse
et dans la bonne direction
ces nouvelles mesures approuvées plus ou
moins par les seize régions seront
revisités le 25 janvier pour décider si
elles seront prolongées en février et au
tour en france alors que plus de 20
mille nouveaux cas de kobe 19 ont été
enregistrés hier emmanuel macron
réunissez ce matin un nouveau conseil de
défense
juste avant le premier conseil des
ministres de l'année les sujets n'ont
pas manqué réouverture des cafés bars et
reste
oran et salles de sport les lieux
culturels ou encore les remontées
mécaniques à la montagne qui n'ouvriront
pas dès demain nous at on déjà prévenu
le premier ministre tiendra une
conférence de presse donc ce sera demain
18 heures aux côtés du ministre de la
santé jean castex devrait détailler de
nouvelles mesures sanitaires
il était aussi question ce matin de la
campagne de vaccination jugée trop lente
le porte parole du gouvernement gabriela
talent a promis une accélération du
déploiement des centres de vaccination
je veux donc d'ores et déjà rappelé
qu'une conférence de presse se tiendra
demain avec le premier ministre et le
ministre des solidarités et de la santé
et que donc un certain nombre de
réponses aux questions que vous serez
amené à me poser seront faites à ce
moment là je peux d'ores et déjà
commencé à répondre aux questions
auxquelles je te répondre pour vous
répondre donc j'ai indiqué dans mon
intervention que le nombre d'hôpitaux
qui permettent de vacciner des soignants
a été multiplié par 3 ce matin qui va
continuer à monter en puissance
et comme vous l'avez rappelé le
président de la république a indiqué 500
à 600 centres dans les prochaines
semaines c'est à dire 5 à 6 par
département mais va-t-on échapper un
troisième rang confinement l'angoissé la
peur qu'elle impacte en tout cas sur
notre psy quai sur notre moral pourront
parler nous sommes avec jean-paul miel
et psychiatres ancien chef de clinique à
l'hôpital sainte-anne bonsoir jean paul
mialet
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france on en parlait il ya quelques
semaines parce que le gouvernement le
ministre de la santé avait fait une
conférence de presse là dessus le moral
des français qui dégringolait depuis on
parle beaucoup de vaccins de restriction
comment vont les français à l'instant t
aujourd'hui est-ce que ça s'aggrave
est-ce que ça va un peu mieux on en
doute
mais bon non non non malheureusement non
aujourd'hui leur moral est de plus en
plus catastrophique est bon il y a de
quoi être abattu quand on quand on vit
au ralenti comme aujourd'hui
chacun vit terrée avec un peu de chance
il a un peu il accueille autour de lui
sa famille mais il n'a plus aucune
possibilité de rencontrer facilement des
amis de sortir et se distraire c'est
très difficile de vivre cette vie
réduite
non bon mauvais et je peux vous dire que
le le deuxième confinement est beaucoup
plus mal supporté que le premier alors
justement a évidemment on craint là non
ça va peut-être pas demain mais mais
c'est vrai que dans d'autres pays
il ya d'autres confirmant de deuxième
pardon d'un deuxième confinement est ce
que ce serait vraiment fatale
justement pour le moral de bon nombre de
nos compatriotes
ce sera un facteur aggravant ça c'est
évident
maintenant c'est l'épidémie progresse
semble-t-il à pas de géants donc il faut
savoir prendre des mesures pour se
protéger
est-ce qu'il vaut mieux empêcher les
gens ne vivent pour la les empêcher de
mourir
je pense que c'est un calcul qui est pas
évident mais c'est quand même sans doute
le confinement toutes ces mesures de
protection 160 août
les seuls qui sont pour le moment
envisagée en attendant le vaccin est ce
que vous estimez que vous en tant que
psychiatre vous avez été assez entendue
par les autorités parce que on parle de
santé on parle d'économie mais on parle
finalement assez peu justement de cet
aspect difficile que traversent les
français ce qu'on en tient suffisamment
compte dans les mesures non je pense
qu'on n'en tiens pas tellement content
parce qu'on se contente de mesures qui
auront des effets sur sur le nombre
d'infections sur le nombre
d'hospitalisations je comprends qu'on
utilise ces critères là mais il ya une
souffrance qui ne se mesurent pas comme
ça par des chiffres et ça certainement
on n'a pas de tenues assez content je
pense aussi d'ailleurs que puisqu'on
parle de souffrance cette souffrance
elle est peut-être plus du côté des
jeunes que du côté ddmt adultes et
encore plus des personnes âgées
on a fait beaucoup de bruit à propos de
la rave party et bien sûr je vais pas
applaudir ces jeunes qui ont fait une
rave party
mais on peut peut-être considérer ça
comme un mouvement de révolte de la part
de jeunes qui ont le sentiment que dans
tout ça ils sont ignorés et qu'on ne
tient compte que des personnes âgées qui
sont finalement les plus visés par le
virus
aujourd'hui 20% de la population
commencerait à basculer dans la
psychiatrie c'est ce qu'affirme et votre
confrère le psychiatre serge hefez sur
europe 1 le 12 décembre
quelles conséquences sur le
long terme est ce qu'on peut se remettre
facilement de ces états je pense que la
fin je ne sais pas sur quels chiffres se
basent mon confrère pense
qu'effectivement depuis longtemps on
sait qu'il y ait une aggravation de
l'angoissé même parfois des idées de
suicide chez hugo grosse partie de la
population les chiffres ont été
multipliées par trois chez les jeunes
américains jeunes jusqu'à 40 ans alors
bon qu'est-ce que de comment on s'en
remet je pense qu'on sort mais assez
facilement
dieu merci l'être humain a des capacités
de rebondissements qui sont très
importantes mais à condition que le
contexte soit porteur je vous dis que ce
sont surtout les jeunes qui sont abîmés
par cette situation
il est évident que si l'économie reprend
dû de façon satisfaisante et qu'ils
peuvent à nouveau envisager un futur
avoir une activité on voir des amis
reprendre une vie normale
eh bien il se remettra au très vite tout
cela mais si par contre cette situation
laisse des traces extrêmement durable
qui entravent leur leur avenir et tous
leurs projets eh bien ils maîtrisent ils
mettront beaucoup de temps à se remettre
parler justement des jeunes et qu'il ya
des fermetures d'écoles dans beaucoup de
pays européens que signifierait un
psychologiquement une fermeture d'école
à nouveau en france pour les enfants
mais aussi parfois pour les parents
là je parle en psychiatrie par un
épidémiologiste on est bien d'accord et
il est l'école est fondamentale et pour
les jeunes parce qu'elle est quand même
le lieu où il fréquente d'autres jeunes
et où ils apprennent à se former à
accumuler des connaissances qu'ils en
seront quand même qu'ils en sont
absolument nécessaires
et puis bah elle est aussi très
profitable pour les parents parce
qu'elle leur donne un moment de liberté
pendant que les enfants sont à l'école
on en n'a pas la responsabilité de la
même façon donc je crois que c'est très
important d'essayer autant que faire se
peut de maintenir des activités
scolaires
merci en tout cas jean paul millet mia
les pardons psychiatre ancien chef de
clinique à l'hôpital
sainte anne merci à vous d'avoir été
avec nous restez avec nous dans quelques
instants nous parlerons de la laïcité
dans nos écoles selon une étude publiée
ce mercredi par l'ifop plus de quatre
enseignants sur dix disent déjà s'être
auto censurer afin d'éviter d'éventuels
incidents avec des élèves
et puis direction à nouveau les états
unis avec ce coup de théâtre
véritablement à washington la séance de
certification de la victoire de joe
biden comme président des états unis a
été suspendu tout à l'heure plusieurs
manifestants ont fait irruption au
congrès conduisant à l'évacuation du
bâtiment la police aurait dégainé ses
armes plusieurs blessés seraient à
déplorer durant des échauffourées c'est
ce que nous annonce à l'instant la
chaîne nbc on y revient tout à l'heure
[Musique]
les chinois ne sont pas des guerriers ce
sont avant tout des commerçants ils ont
négocié avec quinze pays
le partenariat régional économie globale
qui crée la plus grande zone de libre
échange du monde
l'annnonce de sa signature par vidéo à
hanoi bouleverse les équilibres mondiaux
et consacre la perte d'influencé
américaine dans cette partie goût il est
clair qu'avec cet accord le pôle
économique mondiale tentent au niveau du
développement peu de leur activité est
dorénavant durablement installé sur le
continent asiatique avec son est
puissant tranché rendez vous compte un
espace économique occupé par 2 milliards
200 millions d'habitants qui représente
30% de la production mondiale de
richesse il est triste et même
inquiétant de constater que l'europe se
retrouve aujourd'hui marginalisée par
rapport à la rcp
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe
islamisme radical de la saur c'est
l'élite des renseignements généraux de
la police française
c'était après les attentats du 11
septembre et quand on vient vous voir et
qu'on vous dit ben écoutez vous avez de
la première femme qui allait rentrer
dans ce service
vous ne pouvez absolument pas refusé
votre mission première est celle de
traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tranchées pour
reprendre un code policiers il vous a
reconnu que si ben voilà c'est fini pour
moi est ce que je sors mon arme
tout est passé dans ma tête est ce que
vous avez appris de ces profils
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont chercher
d'ailleurs dans la religion le profil
vient toujours de la misère sociale
quand on écoute comme ça du majeur mais
quel est le rapport avec la réducation
mais c'est la radicalisation
il faut que nous reprenions la place
dans le cerveau des enfants et de la
jeunesse
[Musique]
quelle image il laisse de lui diego
maradona en argentine il laisse une
image bas d'une icône absolue d'un dieu
vivant parce qu'il a porté très haut les
couleurs d'un pays qui était humiliée
par la guerre des malouines ce pays a
gagné la coupe du monde alors c'est pas
une victoire militaire mais c'est une
revanche politique et sportif sur une
défaite militaire parce que la politique
et le sport font finalement bon ménage
maradona revendiquait de mélanger sport
et politique dit c'était un homme dutra
gauche on connaît sa proximité avec
castro on connaît sa proximité avec hugo
chavez
il avait cette sensibilité de toujours
incarné bien les dix khamis à dos les
sans-chemise il a toujours joué dans des
clubs qui incarnait la révolte par
rapport au pouvoir central vous êtes en
train de dire finalement diego maradona
c'est l'homme du passé ce cap a un côté
paradoxal le moins que l'on puisse dire
c'est que le personnage n'est pas lisse
et qui a de multiples aspérités et c'est
pour ça que c'est un personnage de
légende
[Musique]
21h30 heure française soyez les
bienvenus en direct sur rt france on en
vient à cette enquête ifop pour la
fondation jean jaurès et charlie hebdo
publié ce mercredi
les contestations de la laïcité les
revendications religieuses vécue par les
enseignants dans l'enceinte scolaire
c'est son nom elle porte vous l'aurez
compris sur la laïcité au sein des
établissements scolaires des résultats
parfois édifiant qui interviennent près
deux trois mois après la décapitation à
conflans sainte honorine de samuel pâtit
tous les détails sur place avec estelle
farges un panorama sur ce que vit vous
ressentent les enseignants français
c'est ce qui est entrepris
l'observatoire de l'éducation de la
fondation jean jaurès un panorama en
trois volets le premier vient d'être
publié il porte sur la façon dont les
professeurs appréhende les questions
religieuses et la laïcité dans leur vie
professionnelle
près de trois mois après l'assassinât de
sa mère pattie ici à conflans sainte
honorine les questions religieuses dans
la vie scolaire serait selon l'anc est
de plus en plus source de tension il ya
d'abord cette autocensure hausse pour
éviter les tensions 49 % des enseignants
soit près d'un sur deux se seraient déjà
auto censuré dans le renseignement des
questions religieuses ses 13 points de
plus qu'en 2018
il serait en revanche plus de la moitié
53% à avoir déjà observé des élèves
contester des enseignements au nom de la
religion que ce soit dans des matières
comme le sport les cours d'éducation
sexuelle ou encore dans des
enseignements portant sur la laïcité
là encore ce phénomène est en hausse + 7
points par rapport à une autre enquête
semblable réalisé il ya trois ans
concernant les formes de séparatisme
religieux et toujours selon cette étude
59% des professeurs y auraient été
confrontés dans leur établissement
actuel
cela concerne par exemple l'absence de
jeunes filles parfois sans aucune
justification
des cours de natation le rejet de la
viande au repas ou encore le refus
d'entrer dans certains lieux religieux
lors de sorties scolaires
après le meurtre de sa mère pattie en
octobre dernier des cérémonies d'hommage
ont eu lieu dans la plupart des
établissements scolaires ainsi un
enseignant sur cinq aurait été témoin de
désapprobation ou de contestation lors
de ces cérémonies 34 % de ces faits se
seraient déroulés au sein du rep
le réseau d'éducation prioritaire enfin
interrogé sur le choix de semelle pâti
de montrer dans son cours les
caricatures de charlie hebdo
représentant le prophète 9% des
enseignants sondés estiment que ce
professeur d'histoire géographie a eu
tort ils sont 75% en revanche à soutenir
sa démarche 16 % préfèrent ne pas se
prononcer une timidité qui démontre bien
à quel point le sujet est devenu
sensible au sein de l'éducation
nationale
en ce début d'année 2021 et cette
question de la laïcité à l'école devient
de plus en plus sensible islam à l'école
le séparatisme religieux doit-on s'en
inquiéter c'est l'objet de notre
décryptage ce soir
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec kevin
bossuet historien et professeur
d'histoire en seine-saint-denis bonsoir
kevin à bossuet maire s'en sort avec
nous à vos côté nadia rayman à militante
associative fondatrice de la brigade des
mers bonsoir nadia rayman à merci d'être
avec nous à vous aussi
plusieurs chiffres que nous ont
interpellés dans ce sondage plusieurs
chiffres plutôt inquiétants faut bien le
dire voici le premier regard des 49 %
des enseignants du secondaire 10 s'auto
censurer un seul enseignant sur deux
s'autocensurent pour éviter les
incidents kevin bossuet vous êtes vous
même un professeur d'histoire en seine
saint denis est ce que ça vous est déjà
arrivé de vous auto censuré pour
justement éviter de mettre de l'huile
sur le feu bon me concernant je peux pas
parler d'auto censure par contre il est
évident que je fais attention à ce que
je fais à ce que je dis par rapport au
public qui est en face de moi il ne
s'agit pas me concernant d'autocensure
simplement il est normal aussi de
s'adapter ou publics qui est en face de
nous
après de manière générale quand je parle
avec mes collègues c'est vrai qu'il ya
beaucoup d'enseignants qui
s'autocensurent tout simplement parce
qu'ils ont peur de rentrer dans une
discussion avec les élèves ils ont peur
d'avoir des réprobations de la part des
parents d'élèves ils ont peur également
de la hiérarchie et je trouve qu après
le meurtre de samuel pâtit bizarrement
ça s'est intensifié il ya une forme de
traumatisme au sein de l'éducation
nationale après ces décapitations ce qui
a produit une forme d'autocensure encore
plus importante de la part de beaucoup
d'enseignants
un autre chiffre 1 qui donne quelques
frissons 53% regarder des professeurs
interrogés déclarent que certains de
leurs enseignants ces enseignements par
dont font l'objet de contestations +12
points quand même par rapport à 2018 les
signes de séparatisme religieux devient
également une réalité à l'école 59 % des
enseignants français disent avoir été
confronté au moins une fois
leur établissement ça vous étonne vous
nadia rayman à il ya longtemps que vous
nous parler de ces sujets il y a une
vraie percée de l'islam au sein de
l'éducation nationale
alors je dis bah alors moi ça m'étonne
pas autant que ça fonctionne
ce qui m'étonne le plus c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on se sent censure par
rapport aux élèves mais aussi par
rapport aux collègues exemple quand
c'est dans les staffs des profs ou par
exemple à la vie scolaire
effectivement vous savez tête un sens à
notre discours parce qu'effectivement
les collègues on reproche souvent que
les d'attention ce que tu dis même
accusé parfois disent l'amour soit par
la part de certains collègues et je
pense que c'est ce que je disais tout à
l'heure
monsieur préfet d'histoire en
seine-saint-denis en fin de compte
bon alors là on a laissé en fin de
compte des parents d'élèves
on a laissé parce qu'il ya
l'administration s'il n'y a pas que les
enseignants
je pense que l'administration aussi n'a
pas à jouer le rôle qu'il fallait pour
effectivement 2 mai et soutenir ces
enseignants qui va enseigner en toute
liberté
parce qu'il ya la représentante parents
d'élèves chaque année le cpu ou autres
et aussi il ya un faux pas oublié un
truc est important entre le primaire et
le collège et à la région il ya une
question aussi de financement derrière
qui est tout ça faites attention parce
que effectivement si par exemple on a
des filles par exemple qui ne viennent
pas par exemple à la piscine ou trou
tout ça les enseignants disent ben c'est
pas grave on l'a mais absente puis c'est
tout en fin de compte qu'il n'ya pas de
solidarité déjà entre enseignants alors
moi je ne suis pas inquiète par rapport
aux élèves parce que les élèves on
arrive quand même un qui peut alors
parler moi qui ai travail social
j'arrive un petit peu à part d'une
famille mais j'ai été plus choqué quand
j'ai vu la première fois qu'il travaille
à l'éducation nationale où j'ai été
médiatrice colère s'étale en seine saint
denis à sevran dont la première réunion
des équipes où j'ai rencontré j'ai dit
aux principales
comment ça se fait qu'il ya énormément
les lettres qui sont absents le vendredi
après midi
il me répond c'est pas grave vu que
c'est justifié par les parents et ça
c'est un chef d'établissement et on sait
qu effectivement pourquoi les élèves
étaient absents
alors plus grave évidemment on l'a vu
avec la sphère samuel pâtit où on a
constaté après enquête en l'absence de
soutien de sa hiérarchie et voir de ses
collègues qui n'ont pas aidé comment on
explique sa kevin bossuet vous qui êtes
justement au coeur du réacteur par
l'acheter parce que finalement devient
une minorité on ans pur voilà à exprimer
une opinion ou voilà comment
explique-t-on non je vais je suis
parfaitement d'accord qui vient dé dit
le problème aussi dans l'éducation
nationale c'est l'idéologie d'un certain
nombre de professeurs il ya quelques
professeurs en effet qui considère que
les valeurs de la république ne sont pas
forcément les valeurs à transmettre que
ce sont des valeurs qui sont un petit
peu litigieuse et c'est vrai qu'il se
rapproche il est le guide et aux
logiques mans de l'islam au gaucher s'il
ya parfois une forme d'un kwh intense
avec les mouvements islamistes et c'est
ça en effet qui est excessivement grave
et puis aussi autre chose cette volonté
si vous voulez de ne pas faire de vagues
parce que c'est vrai qu'on est une
institution qui peut menacer je tiens à
dire que dahesh monastir a menacé
directement les enseignants 2015 à
partir du moment où il défend des les
valeurs de laïcité c'est vrai qu' on est
parfois sur des territoires où les
familles musulmanes sont très importante
donc c'est vrai que quand on est
principal ou proviseurs on se méfie un
petit peu on n'a pas envie de faire de
vagues on achète parfois un petit peu la
paix sociale en faisant preuve me preuve
de mansuétude en ne relevant pas
certains propos et c est à la fin
malheureusement tout ça nous explose au
visage
moi j'aimerais dire aussi autre chose on
n'a pas découvert le problème de
l'islamiste avec la sphère de samuel
pâtit déjà en 2002 avec l' ouvrage les
territoires perdus de la république on
avait mis en avant cette montée de
l'islamisme en 2004 avec le rapport obin
jean pierre robin c'était un haut
fonctionnaire de l'éducation nationale
il avait déjà en 2004 insisté sur la
théologie nation de l'enseignement et
puis en 2012 vous avez quand même
vincent peillon qui est socialiste qui
est de gauche qui avaient
notamment parlé des savoirs que l'on ne
peut plus transmettre c'est vrai qu'il
ya aujourd'hui de gros problèmes
il ya tout un pan des programmes de
l'éducation nationale qu'on ne peut plus
transmettre je pense par exemple à la
choix je pense par exemple au conflit
israélo-palestinien je pense à la guerre
d'algérie je pense à la naissance du
judaïsme mais également dans d'autres
matières par exemple en sciences et vie
de la terre c'est très compliqué
d'aborder par exemple la reproduction
sans faire référence au courant ou sans
justifier son enseignement par rapport
au courant donc c'est très dramatique
l'acide la situation dans laquelle se
trouve l'école de la république mais en
fait l'école de la république n'est que
le reflet de la société quand vous allez
en seine-saint-denis après problèmes
d'islamisation moi il ya un chiffre qui
me maps et l'historien georges
bensoussan qui le met en avant 80 % des
juifs au cours des 15 dernières années
ont fui la seine saint denis tout
simplement parce qu'il ya un
antisémitisme très importante donc vous
comprenez pourquoi nous enseignants en
seine-saint-denis on a des difficultés
par exemple enseigner la joie nadia
rayman à vous dénoncez évidemment la
radicalisation à l'école depuis
plusieurs années vous avez d'ailleurs
travaillé dans un établissement qui vous
a écarté parce que vous dénonciez ces
problèmes quand on vous écoute tous les
deux on peut se demander que fait le
gouvernement le ministre de l'éducation
est ce qu'il y a quand même la prise de
conscience de ces problèmes on imagine
que oui mais en tout cas ce qu'il ya une
réaction surtout alors ce qui est pire
c'est que je vous montrais un document
où il ya écrit ici objets suis
informations menaces de mort j'ai été
menacé de mort suite à la décapitation
de samuel pâtit parce que j'ai soutenu
sa myopathies alors j'aime à
l'établissement scolaire où je travaille
qui m'envoient l'objet suite à une
information de menaces de mort vous avez
le devoir de rester chez vous car vous
n'êtes que à risque
ça c'est le site j'ai reçu ce courrier
le 26 octobre pour avoir manifesté et
parler sur une autre antenne concurrence
en disant qu'effectivement qu'il y avait
un grand islamisme qui m'inquiétait dans
les banlieues lier maga mon chef
d'établissement au lieu de me soutenir
bien
au contraire j'ai une mise à pied
jusqu'à aujourd'hui je n'ai plus repris
mes fonctions alors ça c'est pas
vraiment un problème pour moi parce que
moi je connais le problème qui se passe
c'est que les collègues qui me
soutiennent me soutiennent pas rentrer
et me dit surtout ne dis pas que c'était
des fournées ne dis pas que je te
soutiens et c'est pas je ne travaille
pas actuellement dans un essaim de saint
denis
je travaille dans un grand établissement
à paris où il est cette lâcheté aussi de
dire ne pas parler de ce qui s'est passé
par rapport à ça mais fatigué que je
suis moi je saurai harris pour avoir
dénoncé depuis des années du coup alors
on l'institution se défendent en disant
nous avons 800 élèves à protéger alors
que vous êtes à risque
vous êtes médiatisé vous dénoncer
l'islamisme on va vous exclure
voilà ce que nous répond aujourd'hui
l'objet qui est grave qui écrit suite
d'informations de menaces de mort vu que
vous avez reçu des menaces de mort en
droit vous exclure
voilà ce que c'est c'est ça qui est
grave kevin bossuet le mot de la fin
avec ce chiffre peut-être ça sera la
dernière question 75% des enseignants
ont tout de même soutenu un le choix on
en parlait de cervelle pâti d'avoir
montré les caricatures de presse dans
son cours sur la liberté d'expression
votre réaction c'est plutôt un espoir
pour vous oui je pense que c'est pas un
espoir c'est tout simplement mois sous
mais ce qui me fait peur c'est qu'on ait
quelques semaines après la décapitation
de samuel pâtit et j'ai l'impression en
fait qu il ne se passe absolument rien
on continue la même chose à partir du
moment où on dénonce l'islamisation une
partie de la société on nous dit mais
attention pas d' amalgame où on nous
traite de fasciste mais à la fin
finalement on n'avance pas alors après
c'est vrai que l'éducation nationale
fait ce qu'elle peut avec les moyens
qu'elle avoue parlé tout à l'heure de
jean michel blanquer r je pense que jean
michel blanquer r c'est plutôt un bon
ministre et c'est l'un des rares
ministres qui a mis en avant ses
problèmes d'islamisation dans la société
par exemple en s'opposant au port du
voile
ça des services publics mais c'est vrai
que c'est un petit peu compliqué parce
qu'il n'a pas forcément toujours le
soutien de sa majorité qui le trouve
très à droite je prends par exemple la
loi sur le séparatisme au départ ça doit
être une loi contre l'islam politique et
finalement c'est devenu une loi contre
le séparatisme tout simplement pour ne
pas choquer une partie de la société
française sauf qu'à force de mettre en
avant des tabous à force de ne pas
employer les bons mots on passe à côté
des problèmes et j'ai bien peur que dans
les prochains mois il y ait un second
samuel pâtit donc à un moment donné il
faut écouter les gens du terrain il faut
véritablement agir parce que c'est le
coeur de la république qui en train de
trembler face à une islamisation de plus
en plus importante d'une grande partie
de notre territoire
merci kevin bossuet merci à vous
également n'advient rébéna d'avoir été
avec nous
21h44 en direct sur rt france et on
retourne aux états unis parce qu'il ya
des événements très graves qui s'y
produisent avec ce coup de théâtre à
washington la séance de certification la
victoire de joe biden comme président
des états unis a été suspendu tout à
l'heure mais les choses se sont
envenimées une personne a été blessée
par balle à l'intérieur même du capitole
alors que plusieurs manifestement et ont
fait irruption conduisant d'ailleurs à
l'évacuation du bâtiment les occupants
se sont réfugiés dans les souterrains
sous le congrès des gaz lacrymogènes ont
été utilisés dans la rotonde du capitole
les armes des policiers également là
de washington a décrété un couvre-feu à
partir de 18h heure locale je me disais
des policiers qui dégainent leurs armes
dans le bâtiment pour protéger les élus
écoutez le témoignage de raleigh
cévennes ce député américaine du
michigan qui indique sur twitter s'être
mis à l'abri dans son bureau je me suis
mise à l'abri dans mon bureau
le bâtiment d'à côté a été évacué je
n'arrive pas à croire ce que j'écris
mais de son côté le président américain
avait appelé ses partisans à éviter les
violences pourtant quelques heures plus
tôt donald trump a tenu un discours très
offensif le milliardaire américain mais
mis à la pression sur son vice président
mike pence pour ne pas proclamer joe
biden vainqueur lors de cette
certification qui devait donc se
dérouler en ce moment même au congrès je
vous propose de l'écouter lui tous ici
présents ne voulons pas voir notre
victoire électorale volés par des
démocrates plein d'audace de la gauche
radicale car c'est ce qu'ils ont fait
est volé par les pseudo médias ce qu'ils
sont en train de faire n'abandonnerons
jamais nous ne procéderons jamais
[Applaudissements]
et j'espère que mike pence fera ce qu'il
faut je l'espère je l'espère parce que
si mike pence serait la bonne chose nous
gagnons l'élection tout ce qu'il a à
faire et cela vient du numéro un où
certainement de l'un des meilleurs
avocats en droit constitutionnel de
notre pays
il a le droit absolu de le faire nous
sommes censés protéger notre pays
soutenir notre pays soutenir notre
constitution et protéger notre
constitution et nous sommes en direct
pour parler de ces derniers évènements
lors de la séance du congrès suspendu
avec gérald ollivier journaliste analyse
franco-américain bonsoir gérald olivier
des événements inattendus on imagine que
vous le spécialiste des états unis vous
devez être à uhry de ventre devant votre
télévision voyant ces images de
violences devant le capitole dans ce
qu'ils appellent la plus grande
démocratie du monde
oui alors attention à ce qu'on dit
attention à ce qu'on voit attention à ce
qui se passe et attention à ce qui est
derrière on a vu on a entendu des le
fait qu'il y aurait eu des coups de feu
qui était échangé intérieur du capitole
ce qui est évidemment extrêmement grave
c'est extrêmement préoccupant les images
qu'on a de l'extérieur du capitole
pour moi ce n'est pas de la violence
même si même si les manifestations et
les manifestants ne devrait pas ainsi
investir cette maison encore que le
capitole techniquement après tout c'est
la maison du peuple
mais au-delà de cela pour moi ces
événements sont la manifestation
évidente d'une frustration qui a été
ignorée qui a été repoussée qui a été
bafoué pendant des semaines et des
semaines jeudi frustration des
supporters de trump parce que ils sont
convaincus il ya pas mal d'éléments qui
vont dans leur sens ils sont convaincus
que l'élection a été le résultat de
fraude que la victoire de joe biden est
il légitime et leurs plaintes ont été
totalement ignoré y compris par les
médias elles ont été moqués par les
démocrates qui ont dit mauvais joueur
elles ont été délibérément ignorée par
les médias et à l'arrivée on a ce genre
d'explosion parce qu'aujourd'hui on est
au dernier jour d'un processus qui
jusqu'à présent se dérouler selon les
règles institutionnelles et là les
règles institutionnelles et bien elles
ont éclaté manifestement mais cette
frustration
elle a été entretenue elle a été
préparée je dirais même qu'elle a été
d'une certaine façon manipulés par des
gens qui ont prétendu que les électeurs
de 30 n'existait pas et qu'on pouvait
faire tout ce qu'on voulait avec eux que
trump était un personnage qui n'était
pas respectable qui n'était pas légitime
à la présidence ça fait quatre ans
les démocrates nous disent qu'il n'est
pas le président légitime alors qu'il
est parfaitement et qu'il l'est encore
aujourd'hui et alors que son mandat se
termine et que son successeur est élu
sur des lignes qui sont très
contestables et avec des façons qui sont
très contestables
eh bien on a cette explosion que je ne
justifie pas que jeune que je n'admets
pas que je n'approuve pas et j'espère
qu'il n'y aura pas de victime ou que ça
n'ira pas au delà la nuit avis que
d'être longue à washington mais ce qu'on
observe pour moi c'est ce que les
démocrates ont cherché à obtenir depuis
quatre ans et ils ont tout fait pour
c'est une analyse effectivement à
entendre et on y reviendra il n'empêche
gérald olivier c'est vrai que sur les
images à l'extérieur du capitole les
choses semblent plus ou moins calme un
d'ailleurs on apprend que la garde
américaine nationale américaine a été
envoyé à washington un couvre-feu a été
établi les choses sont quand même assez
importante
les médias américains rapportent qu'une
personne a été blessée par balle et elle
se trouve dans un état sérieux il ya
quelques images d'ailleurs qui circule
sur les réseaux sociaux ont des images
assez forte
on pouvait tout de même imaginer ce
genre de situation au capitole encore
une fois au coeur même de la démocratie
américaine
écoutez je ne veux pas reprendre ce que
je viens de dire
bon moi je me l'imaginais pas qu'il y
ait ce genre de dérapages parce que là
on est même on est même au delà du
dérapage et ce sont des images
extrêmement préoccupante et extrêmement
je dirais blessantes difficile à
supporter contre quand on aime
démocratie américaine mais encore une
fois je regrette vraiment que les choses
en soient arrivés là et elle en soit
arrivé là parce que les supporters de
trump ont été ont été ont été ignorés en
permanence ils ont été comment dirais-je
décrédibiliser pendant quatre ans de
même que la politique du président et
ils se sont aperçus à l'arrivée que
l'élection se déroulait de façon tout à
fait contestable et de son bouillant
pardonnez moi parce qu'effectivement on
avait compris ce message mais il ya
quand même eu des recours alors c'est
vrai que les médias américains
excepté fox news évidemment on était
trop trompé dans ce sens sont jamais
cachés mais il ya quand même eu des
recours judiciaires après cette élection
rejetée notamment par par la cour
suprême sauf erreur de ma part donc sert
qu'on judiciaire ils ont bien eu lieu
n'est ce pas oui ils ont bien eu lieu
maintenant il est très difficile de
mettre en place un dossier légal en en
quelques en en quelques quelques jours
pour que une contestation soit accepté
surtout que et c'est très important la
plupart de ses recours ont été rejetés
sur des défauts de procédure et sur le
fait que même si le recours était été
acceptée il ne concernait pas un nombre
de votes suffisant pour inverser le
résultat vendant dans l'état en question
à partir de là ça servait à rien de
reconnaître la plate puisque même si le
le le plaintif avec anne cause le
résultat de l'élection ne serait pas
changé ce qu'il ya c'est qu'on a un
faisceau de jeu direct de comportement
de d'irrégularités de le plat une
élection qui laisse vraiment un goût
très amer
donc voilà maintenant la justification
elle est là l'émotion elle est là mais
je ne tiens absolument pas à soutenir ce
qui est en train de se passer au
capitole c'est quelque chose qui jamais
vue aux états unis c'est quelque chose
qui va rester en terme d'image et qui
d'ailleurs va évidemment nuire à donald
trump parce que là le mandat de donald
trump sera résumée en quelques images
qu'on est en train de voir faut pas
qu'il se fasse d'illusions et donc tout
ce qui tout ce qui s'était passé qui
avait été positif pendant quatre ans et
bien s'effondre parce que justement on à
cela et je le répète je pense que les
démocrates ont travaillé sur l'émotion
merci gérald olivier fait du problème de
liaison merci en tout cas d'avoir été
avec nous pour commenter ces événements
qui se déroulent en
moment même à washington et on termine
cette émission avec la russie des images
plus légère en les célébrations de noël
pour les chrétiens orthodoxes on
retrouve en direct verhaeghe hoffman
notre correspondante à moscou depuis la
cathédrale du christ sauveur bonsoir
verra ravi de vous retrouver en direct
de moscou et la pandémie de coronavirus
at elle une incidence verra sur les
fêtes de noël en russie
bonsoir stéphanie oui effectivement la
pandémie du courant à virus a affecté
cette année et les messe orthodoxe de du
noël
il ya notamment les restrictions les
églises sont obligés de se plier aux
restrictions sanitaires cette année le
patriarche de l'église orthodoxe kirill
a notamment demandé aux paroissiens âgés
de plus de 65 ans souffrant de maladies
chroniques graves ne pas se rendre dans
les églises et acide ne pas assister la
liturgie et de noël à la retransmission
de la messe de la cathédrale christ
sauveur vous l'entendez derrière moi va
être retransmise par plusieurs chaînes
fédérales et d'autres églises organise
des retransmissions des liturgies par
internet le nombre d'opérations dans les
églises est également limitée la
cathédrale du christ sauveur derrière
moi normalement peut accueillir jusqu'à
dix mille paroissiens en une seule la
liturgie et cette année l'entrée se fait
uniquement sur l'invitation et seulement
pour 350 personnes chacun sera obligé de
porter un masque des gants à respecter
la distanciation sociale les mêmes
gestes barrières sont obligatoires dans
toutes les églises russes
en tout cas effectivement les cloches
sont vains magnifique sont chères verra
gassmann on vous entend quand même
est-ce que vladimir poutine va assister
la liturgie de noël
[Musique]
le président russe vladimir poutine n'a
pas pour habitude d'assister à la
liturgie de noël dans la cathédrale
principal donc christ sauveur mais par
contre il va se rendre cette année dans
une petite église au nord de la russie à
côté de la ville de novgorod celle de
saint nicolas sur l'hypnose est une des
plus vieilles églises sur le territoire
us elles datent du xiiie siècle et se
trouve sur un neil dans un sur un lac du
maine
merci verhaeghe hoffman en direct donc
depuis la cathédrale du christ sauveur à
moscou et c'est la fin de cette émission
se retrouve dans quelques petites
minutes pour 1 point complet sur
l'actualité on reviendra évidemment sur
les événements qui se déroulent en ce
moment même à washington aux etats unis
[Musique]
vous insistez beaucoup sur l'aspect des
dépenses publiques ce que je critique
c'est que on est dans un état
d'addiction de grande dépendance à la
dépense publique je ne veux pas du sang
et des larmes le son et les dames on les
a trop de dépenses trop d'état je pense
en tout cas qu'il ya trop de
bureaucratie c'est à dire un état
inefficace tout ça a été financée
essentiellement par de la dette
le problème est moins la dette en
réalité moi je pense qu'on remboursera
la dette par la croissance donc il faut
essayer de libérer l'économie française
et notamment le travail
notre problème en france c'est un
problème où la dépense publique est
excessive
mais surtout elle